Platte dran. Aber die habe ich nicht
gemountet, wenn ich mich mit meinem Streaming
Profil einblocke, weil ich will
nicht aus Versehen irgendwelche Sachen
leaken.
Und das NAS habe ich auch nicht gemountet.
Ansonsten komme
ich auch auf deutlich mehr.
Allein
die ZFS-Kiste, die hinter mir steht, hat 20TB.
Auch das ist die,
wo ich seit einem Jahr sage, die kommt weg.
Aber sie ist immer noch da.
Ja, zu
diesen Geschichten mit Windows C-Doppelpunkt,
nee, Doppelpunkt, warum das so heißt,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Eigentlich
habe ich jetzt gehofft, der Chat sagt, ja, nee, warum
ist das so? Und dann kann ich sagen, weil ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe nämlich
keine Ahnung, warum das so ist.
Ich finde es nur unglaublich unsinnig,
die Windows-Bezeichnung.
Ich meine,
dass es C-Doppelpunkt für die Festplatte ist,
kann ich mir noch erklären,
weil A und B Diskettenaufwerke waren.
Aber
warum man überhaupt auf diese
Bezeichnung kommt?
Ich muss sagen, da kommt mir die Unix-Geschichte
mit Slash als Root
deutlich sinnvoller vor.
Moment, warum?
Moment, Leute.
Warum um alles in der Welt ist hier
Best of Vivaldi offen?
Es ist der Vivaldi-Browser,
aber warum?
Ah, yes.
Excellent Musik.
Exquisite.
Ah, yes.
Ah, Five Head Wine, Leute.
So, jetzt erstmal hier
25-jähriger
schottischer Premium-Whisky
aufmachen.
Ah, yes, excellent.
Da muss ich quasi eine Musik dazu.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das auf war, ehrlich gesagt.
WTF-Bait.
Natürlich war ich das nicht.
Das ist Orangensaft, der hier steht.
Als hätte ich 25-jährigen schottischen Whisky
da.
Aber könnte man.
Ja, ist doch kein Ding.
Die sind gar nicht...
Also, je nachdem was, ist es gar nicht so teuer.
Also, für 20, 30 Euro
gibt es da schon ganz gutes Zeug.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie der
Excellent-Whisky-Experte wäre oder so.
Okay, erstmal.
Erstmal downloaden.
Und zwar, ich habe heute...
Deswegen bin ich auf die Idee gekommen.
Wir müssen uns das ganz mal angucken.
Ich habe heute, war ich doch bei Hacker-News?
Irgendwo habe ich gelesen, dass irgendwie Solo
4.1 oder so rausgekommen ist.
Das ist eine Linux-Distribution,
von der habe ich ab und zu schon mal was gehört.
Aber hatte nie das großartige...
Oder nee, ist schon ein paar Tage her.
Aber egal, ich habe es heute irgendwo gelesen.
Nie das großartige Bedürfnis.
Seit wann nutzt du Vivaldi?
Seit er rausgekommen ist eigentlich.
Aber ich benutze alle möglichen Browser.
Guck mal.
Ich meine, wir haben Vivaldi,
Chromium, Chrome,
Edge,
Internet Explorer und Edge 9.
Und Firefox.
Wir haben alles drauf.
Das einzige, was uns noch fehlt, ist Opera.
Aber den sehe ich kein Content zu installieren.
Gut.
Und ich habe heute ein Review gelesen.
Oder so eine Übersicht.
Ich glaube, bei Hacker-News war es.
Ich muss die Musik ein bisschen
reiser machen.
Genau.
Und zwar,
die haben einen eigenen Desktop entwickelt.
Die haben hier nämlich
einen BUDGY-Desktop.
Warum auch immer,
dass sie noch einen extra Desktop brauchen unter Linux.
Keine Ahnung.
Weil das halt
exzellent ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest habe ich mir gedacht,
gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Es sieht für mich aus ein bisschen wie eine Gnome Shell.
Aber ich glaube, ist es nicht.
Der ist noch luxurierter.
Steht da.
Ah, doch, doch.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das eine Gnome Shell ist.
Oder ob das nur was ist, was auf GTK basiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Deswegen, das probieren wir aus.
Ansonsten haben die noch ähnliche Sachen zur Auswahl,
wie Dings, na, wie heißt Ubuntu-Dings hier?
Mint.
Ähnliche Sachen.
Die haben hier Mate haben die zur Auswahl noch.
Die haben irgendeine Gnome-Variante.
Die haben Plasma.
Plasma ist wahrscheinlich irgendeine KDE-Geschichte oder so.
Plasma klingt irgendwie nach KDE.
Ja, also sie haben alles Mögliche.
Aber hier diese diese BUDGY-Variante ist wohl das von denen entwickelte.
Übrigens, wir haben ein paar neue Emotes.
Leider ist mein Vorschau so kaputt, dass ich sie mir nicht anzeigen lassen kann.
Ich habe ein paar neue Emotes reingemacht, allerdings keine Sub-Emotes,
sondern, äh, äh, FFZ-Emotes oder Better-Twitch-TV-Emotes habe ich ein paar reingemacht.
Ein paar neue.
Zum Beispiel PepoClap und, und ein paar andere.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ihr könnt ja mal ausprobieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich alles reingemacht habe.
Fünf, sechs Stück nur.
Weil ich habe gesehen, dass man bei Better-Twitch-TV jetzt anstatt 25 irgendwie auf einmal 80 Emotes oder so haben kann.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach random ein paar Emotes reingeklickt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was mit Better-Twitch-TV los ist.
Wahrscheinlich wollen sie, dass mehr Leute fünf Euro
im Monat bezahlen
für Better-Twitch-TV-Premium.
Genau, Trigger ist auch dabei.
Pepega ist schon lange dabei, das ist nichts Neues.
Die, der, der, der, der Livestream
habt ihr eigentlich schon.
Leute, wer von euch verwendet FFZ?
Ich muss euch nämlich mal was zeigen.
Muss, ich muss euch mal was zeigen.
Ähm, wir machen das jetzt.
Wir machen das jetzt mal im Chrome.
Ähm, ich muss euch nämlich mal was zeigen.
FFZ hat
also, beziehungsweise was zeigen und was fragen, die dies verwenden.
Ja, Erweiterung hinzufügen.
Alles gut.
Okay, weil Twitch
Roblox
ähm, FFZ hat jetzt
naja, ich stimme zu, machen wir hier jetzt mal dicht.
FFZ hat jetzt ein neues
hm
Moment, wo, wo ist es denn?
FFZ hat ein neues Feature
nämlich
ein
hier, guckt mal.
Ah, man sieht sich.
FFZ hat jetzt hier unten so einen, so einen Equalizer-Ding
oder Kompressor.
Ja, das ist richtig nice.
Jetzt ist es halt ein bisschen
ein bisschen kaputt, ja.
Das hat so ein Equalizer-Feature.
Das ist hyper, hyper nice.
Ja, das da meine ich.
Das bringt richtig was.
Also, alle, die es nicht haben, kann ich das nur empfehlen, mal auszuprobieren.
Ähm, weil
es ist auf Twitch, jeder Streamer hat irgendwie
ein bisschen
andere
Audio-Settings, ja.
Und ich finde, die haben ein ziemlich gutes Preset
aus, äh
Hör, Hörbarkeit von, von Streamer-Commentary
und gleichzeitig Ingame-Sound, auch wenn da Streamer
und Hintergrundmusik, das haben die echt gut gemacht.
FFZ Franker faces
sie.
Franker sie, Franker sie, Franker sie, Frank.
Ja, und das ist das Beste, das Beste hier, FFZ.
Aber wenn wir gerade dabei sind, da können wir auch gerade mal gucken, was ich für neue Emotes reingemacht habe.
Weil die sieht, weil die sieht man ja hier schön dann.
Und zwar, wir haben
die, hallo?
Huge Loading.
Vielleicht, vielleicht wagt es jetzt damit rum.
Emotes.
Funktioniert richtig gut.
Weiß nicht, warum es jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Eigentlich ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Kann es sein, dass der Emote-Server gerade irgendwie down ist von denen?
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen, dass das nicht lädt.
Lustig.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das, dass das geht, dass das nicht lädt.
Bei mir läuft's, ja.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was die gerade für Schmerzen haben, aber
anscheinend ist gerade ein bisschen kaputt.
Monka, ah, Monka S.
Okay, das andere lädt nicht.
Super, das ist gerade voll kaputt.
Wie gesagt, das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen und das, und eine Sache müsst ihr machen.
Eine Sache müsst ihr unbedingt machen, wenn ihr FFZ installiert habt.
Nämlich, ihr müsst GIF-Emotes einschalten.
Die aus irgendwelchen Gründen jetzt nicht drinne sind.
Ah, das ist, weil ich die Better Twitch TV Emotes installiert hab, ne?
Genau, Add-ons, ich muss erst den Kram aktivieren.
Ja.
Kann man den Kram vergrößern.
Muss jetzt erst mal Better Twitch TV Emotes aktivieren.
Und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert das nämlich auch.
Und da muss man hier unbedingt sagen, GIF animierte Emotes.
Sonst, sonst funktioniert's nicht.
Und wenn man jetzt nämlich reloadet, dann funktioniert nämlich der Kram.
Und wenn ich jetzt sag hier, Coggers, dann geht auch, naja gut, ich kann jetzt nicht.
Ach, wahrscheinlich kann ich nicht laden, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin.
Naja, bestes, bestes Emote.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir da jetzt drauf gekommen sind.
Sag mal.
Kann die?
Kann die Hintergrundmusik sich mal überlegen, was man, wie, wie laut sie sein möchte?
Gut, aber zurück zu dem eigentlichen, was wir machen wollen.
Nämlich Solos und Linux ausprobieren.
Ähm, laden wir den ganzen Kram hier mal runter.
Excellent Download.
Yes.
Bim, bim, bim.
Genau, den Haha-Typ hab ich auch noch da drin.
Am besten, aber am besten ist, ist, ist.
PeepoClap.
Leute, ihr müsst mal alle, müsst mal alle ausprobieren.
Bestes neues Emote.
PeepoClap.
Äh, ich glaub, ich hab jede Menge im Chat übersehen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ähm.
Boah, nö.
Wenn ich so durchscrolle.
Oh, Turitz.
Twitch Prime.
Huge Sub.
Kann das sein, dass ich keinen Subscriber-Sound hab?
Ist mein Subscriber-Sound kaputt?
Ich glaub, ne, aber ohne Mist.
Ich glaub, der ist wirklich kaputt.
Hm.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ich mach mal einen Test-Sound.
Streamlabs.
Stream, äh, Streamlabs, nicht Steamlabs.
Warum ist auf jedem Werbebild von Twitch Pokimane eigentlich drauf?
Ich mein, außer, dass er gut ausschaut, find ich den Stream jetzt, meine persönliche Meinung, nicht sonderlich spannend.
So, wir machen jetzt mal einen Alert.
Ne, funktioniert.
Funktioniert.
Äh, kurze Frage, was ist dein Favorite Linux?
Ähm.
Manjaro mit i3-WM.
Gidi, Conno, dankeschön.
PeepoClap.
Huge Sub.
Prime.
Und das bediene ich über den Browser auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Okay, Download fertig.
Dann gucken wir jetzt mal, dass wir eine VM anlegen.
Allerdings eine VM auf der zweiten SSD.
Dann probieren wir das Ganze mal aus.
BSP-WM, E3-WM.
Warum?
Ich habe letztens ein Video darüber gesehen.
Ich war jetzt nichts dabei, wo ich gesagt hätte, oh ja, das muss unbedingt, brauche ich das.
Was ist Asianux?
Nie gehört.
Oracle-E-Gig.
So, und das machen wir jetzt nicht da, sondern da.
Äh, äh, Solus.
Nächst.
Ähm, drei CPUs sollte reichen.
4G-RAM, NAT, EXT, EXT, RAID, äh, ne Wurscht, 80, haben genug, Single-File.
Hast du auch mal ein Interesse an den FreeBSD oder andere OS aus der BSD-Familie?
Äh, ja, können wir machen, aber ich muss sagen, BSD habe ich ganz wenig Ahnung von.
Das Einzige von BSD, was ich weiß, ist, dass die wohl eine große globale Config-Datei haben.
Das war's.
Das Einzige, wo ich bisher live Kontakt mit BSD hatte, ist FreeNAS und OpenSense.
Das automatische Teilnehmer.
Okay, wir schmeißen das erste Mal den Printer raus, den brauchen wir nämlich garantiert nicht.
Rest lassen wir da.
Finish.
So, legen wir das ISO rein und gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Downloads, Solus, Bougie.
Übrigens, äh, Twitch-Chat.
Wir haben uns ja schon so ein paar Inderspeicher.
Scam-Videos angeguckt auf YouTube.
Und da habt ihr mich immer gefragt, ob ich Kid Boga kenne auf Twitch.
Und ich hab immer gesagt, äh, sagt mir nix, also ich kenn den Channel, hab ich nie geguckt.
Ich hab letztens mal geguckt, ne, der Typ ist richtig gut.
Der ist eigentlich viel zu überqualifiziert für Twitch.
Der könnte damit irgendwo eine komplett eigene Sendung machen.
Der ist richtig gut.
Also, der hat's drauf, was Inderscammer vermittelt.
Was das mit Verarschen angeht.
Der ist huge.
Ja.
Vor allem, wie kreativ der ist, was ihm zwischendurch einfällt, während er mit denen telefoniert.
Also der ist wirklich gut.
Äh, ich hab letztens mal angemacht, hab ich gar nicht mit gerechnet.
Und richtig gut.
Automatic Boot.
Mal gucken, wohin es bootet.
Best of of YouTube.
Ja, ich hab ein bisschen so ein bisschen...
Den Stream dann noch nachgeguckt.
Ähm...
Ja, das mit Edmar kenn ich mit der Oma.
Natürlich nicht komplett, ja.
Und vor allem, dass er dann auch irgendwann noch, ähm...
Wie heißen sie?
Alex und...
Adam und Alex?
Die zwei Inder.
Dass er die dann noch öfters auch schon reingekriegt hat.
Übelst nice.
Okay, es fühlt sich übelst schnell an.
Obwohl es ne Live-CD ist.
Aber muss ja sagen, es ist ja ne Live-CD von...
Ja.
Von USB, äh, von Platte.
Wie installiert man das denn?
Hiermit, ha?
Schauen wir mal, ob die in der Lage sind...
V.a. Tools zu installieren.
Bis die das hingekriegt haben, stretchen wir das Ganze.
Dass wir hier die richtige...
Cut-Noob-Installer-Experience haben.
Dass wir hier die richtige... Cut-Noob-Installer-Experience haben.
Englisch, United States...
So, brauchen wir das.
Wo hab ich mein Kokona?
Kokona, wo ist mein Kokona? Ah, ja. Ach.
Passend.
Kokona-Language.
Where are you?
Find my locat... Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Finde nur den Stimmverzerrer ein wenig...
Das braucht der, die kennen den ja alle.
Die Inder checken das sogar schon immer.
So nach dem Motto, Kitboga, Kitboga, Kitboga.
Die kapieren das schon alle, die Inder.
Das ist...
Der braucht den Stimmverzerrer.
Oh, ich sehe gerade, dass hier...
Big Brain-Diskussion über...
Samarin und...
Cross-Platform-Kotlin-Java-Entwicklung gibt.
Ah, yes, exquisite Chat heute wieder.
Big Brain-Chat.
Schneebär ist auch am Start.
So, falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, Leute, im Chat,
dann müsst ihr das nochmal schreiben mit
Edwublos.
So, next. Mal gucken.
Wir sind in Europe Berlin.
Ja.
Ja, wir sind 500 Kilometer weg oder so.
Ja, wir sind 500 Kilometer weg oder so. Aber das ist... Ja, so.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Äh, ich will... Nein, ich will
No-Dead-Keys.
Ist das das Gleiche wie No-Dead-Keys?
Warum gibt es drei...
Das habe ich noch nie verstanden, ne?
Warum es so 50 Milliarden
Abwandlungen von Tastatur-Layouts bedarf?
Habe ich noch nie gecheckt, ehrlich.
Noch nie.
Und dann heißen die teilweise
noch anders.
Ich nehme immer No-Dead-Key, weil...
Äh, No-Dead-Key,
dann kann man hier den Kram hier
ordentlich einfügen.
Ja, die Location, klar,
war die 042-Zone.
Da sind wir. Berlin.
Next.
Äh...
Mach.
Mach alles automatisch.
Ach, Quatsch. Wir brauchen auch kein LVM
hier.
Install a bootloader. Timehostname.
Cute.
Chat.
Next.
Warum kann ich nicht installieren?
Ah, Hostnames must be lowercase.
Das war zu viel verlangt, dass man
ähm, too lower macht.
Übrigens, Leute,
kurze Unterbrechung für eine Runde
C++-Rant.
Vielleicht habe ich das im Stream schon
gemacht, aber ich muss mich ja öfters mal
über C++ aufregen im Stream.
Wusstet ihr, dass
C++
Standard Library
oder STL, wie das da heißt,
ähm,
wusstet ihr,
dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt,
einen Text
in Großschreibweise,
also einen String to Upper
zu konvertieren?
Build-in in der Standard Library?
Das kann jede
noch so beschissene Hobby-Programmiersprache
Build-in in der Standard Library.
Jede.
Mir fällt keine ein, die das nicht kann.
Aber in C++ geht's
nicht.
In C++ gibt es...
Das ist so hässlich.
Ist nicht performant genug.
Genau.
Macht man nie. Macht man nie.
Das muss man lieber selbst programmieren.
Das sind dann viel performanter.
Guckt euch mal an, wie hässlich das in C++ ist.
Hier. Hier. Hallo.
Seid ihr noch ganz dicht?
Die wollen ernst sind.
Also ich weiß nicht,
was mit dem C++-Gremium los ist.
Die wollen
ernsthaft, dass man
String to Upper
von Hand macht.
Es ist keine
Build-in-Funktion
dafür vorgesehen.
Was ist mit den C++-Leuten los?
Warum gibt's sowas nicht?
Ich mach jetzt jeden Stream
10 Minuten mit C++-Rant,
weil mir laufen Dinge auf.
Ich hab mir sogar extra
ein Textdokument gemacht.
C++ sackt.
Und dann schreib ich alles rein, was mir
an C++ auf den Sack geht.
Und das ist jetzt schon 80 Zeilen lang.
Und eins, was mir letztens wieder aufgefallen ist,
es gibt kein Standard-Library
String to Upper.
Es gibt so ein Crap hier wie Standard to Upper
und angeblich
mit C++20
gibt's dann
irgendwas, was es einfacher macht
oder so.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was mit den
Jungs los ist.
Ich kann es mir nicht erklären.
So, starten wir die Installation.
Ah, yes, C++.
Es ist, es ist wir.
Ehrlich.
Username.
Ah, ja, ja.
Passwort.
123456.
Ups, vertippt.
Add.
Admin. Natürlich Admin. Was sonst?
Als bei einem anderen Account als Admin.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ähm, Englisch.
German Keyboard.
Äh,
ja, Partitionier, User,
System Details, alles klar, Install.
Yes.
Warum probiert er so viele Discos aus?
Um sie auszuprobieren.
Der einzige Grund, um sie auszuprobieren.
Ich hab ja schon meine Lieblings-Distro,
die ich tagtäglich auch auf der Arbeit verwende.
Aber ich will einfach mal gucken, was es sonst so gibt.
Und es ist eine schöne Sache
für einen Stream, zum Zeug auszuprobieren.
Ja.
Time Library.
C++ Standardlib.
Wer sich das ausgedacht hat, ey.
Es hat
eine gewisse Logik, muss man sagen.
Aber es ist, es ist
eklig. Es ist, es ist alles.
Es ist wirklich fast alles,
was ich mir an einfachen Aufgaben
so überlegen kann,
ist in C++ eklig zu machen.
Da suchst du, da suchst du auf,
auf Stack Overflow danach,
weil du halt irgendwie feststellst,
okay, so einfach ist es nicht.
Und dann schlägt dir einer vor,
ach, ist doch ganz easy, schreib erst mal zwei Seiten Templates.
So Sachen, wo ich mir denke,
what, was wird euch los bei C++?
Sogar,
und das heißt schon was,
sogar in JavaScript
ist das Daytime Handling einfacher
als in C++.
Und JavaScript Daytime Handling
ist ein Sammelsurium
aus alt,
mittel, neu,
neu und ganz neu.
Wofür benutzt du eigentlich Distros?
Wie?
Du kannst Linux ohne die Distro
nicht benutzen. Irgendjemand
muss das für dich bauen. Oder du machst immer
vom Scratch, aber das macht wahrscheinlich
kaum jemand von uns.
Eero,
drei Monate aktuell, im ersten fortlaufenden
Monat. Das ist Huge Brain
von Twitch, dass es das anzeigt.
Im ersten fortlaufenden Monat,
das heißt im Endeffekt dann jetzt neu,
oder heißt es
erster fortlaufender Monat?
Es ist der zweite Monat, wo du in Folge
abonniert hast.
Wer weiß, fängt Twitch
bei 0 an, wie sich das gehört?
Oder bei 1?
Das heißt erster Resub.
Wahnsinn, dankeschön für den
Resub.
Restart.
Oh, der ist schon fertig. Fortitude.
Klingt wie ein Item
aus Diablo.
Ein, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
So,
jetzt müssen wir erstmal wieder einstellen,
dass wir das Stretchen ausmachen.
Mal gucken, ob die so...
Hm.
Warum schafft es eigentlich keine Distribution,
VMware Tools standardmäßig
zu installieren?
Warum?
Das ist doch kacke.
Ich verstehe nie, warum so viele Leute sagen,
was, das Linux ist besser,
man kann darin dasselbe machen, lol.
Linux
ist weder besser noch schlechter,
genauso wie MacOS oder
Windows besser noch schlechter ist.
Man muss halt einfach gucken, was man für was
verwendet. Wenn ich was
spielen will, verwende ich garantiert kein Linux.
Wenn ich
Netzwerktechnisch was machen will,
oder rumbasteln will, verwende ich
garantiert kein Windows. Und
wenn ich irgendwelchen
irgendwelche huge IQ
Grafikdesign machen
will, dann verwende ich wahrscheinlich
Mac.
Eigentlich ist dieser
Betriebssystem,
den die Leute da sich im Kopf
zurecht zusammendichten,
ist kompletter Schwachsinn.
Man nimmt einfach das,
was für die Sache,
die man machen will, am besten ist.
Unter MacOS hast du beispielsweise
das Problem, wenn du
ähnliche Sachen willst,
wenn du das verwenden willst für
Spiele kannst du auch vergessen,
aber viele Sachen unter MacOS sind einfach
nur alt und musst erstmal 3 Stunden
nachinstallieren, was Unix Tools und
Sachen angeht.
Auf was
basiert das denn überhaupt?
Wir brauchen erstmal eine Konsole.
Terminal.
Wir müssen vor allem Tools nachinstallieren.
Wie macht man das?
Wie installiert man
hier, was hat
so los?
IOPK
Oh.
Das ist ja wirklich mal was eigenes
zur Abwechslung.
Open VM Tools.
Install. Jawoll.
Brauchen wir.
Open VM Tools.
Gut. Und dann brauchen wir
noch, ist das kaputt?
Und dann brauchen wir noch
VM Maus
und
mal erst einen Bug schon gefunden.
Man kommt dann richtig zurück.
Ah, ist alles drauf. Okay.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Oder ob wir erstmal rebooten müssen.
Hier wahrscheinlich müssen wir erstmal rebooten.
Oder
VM
Open
VM User
Hier. Normalerweise muss man das starten.
Okay.
Wir rebooten mal und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert.
Und nebenbei gucken wir, wie wir das machen.
Zodos Forever Tools.
Three years ago.
Open VM Tools.
Warum Bing?
Weil es Default ist.
Ich habe hier in Vivaldi
noch gar nichts umgestellt.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Vielleicht geht es ja auch einfach.
Ah, ne. Mist.
Ich dachte, es geht jetzt einfach.
Okay, was muss man da jetzt alles starten dafür?
Erstmal root werden.
Immer root werden, weil
Start
VM
Yes.
Ah, jetzt. Exzellent.
Easy.
Geht.
Enable.
Tag.
Es laggt. Leute.
Es laggt. Huge lag.
Seht ihr das?
5 FPS.
Was haben wir?
60 FPS haben wir angeblich.
Das fühlt sich definitiv nicht an wie 60 FPS.
Ist 3D.
3D-Beschleunigung aktiviert.
Ah.
Da haben wir schon ein Problem, woran es liegen könnte.
Machen wir mal aus.
Und machen 3D-Beschleunigung an.
Gucken, ob es dann besser funktioniert.
Accelerate.
Normalerweise verwende ich
jetzt hauptsächlich DuckDuckGo
als Search Engine.
Bin da eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit.
Es war so schleichend.
Ich fand Google
jetzt nie als Firma so geil.
Aber ich habe komplett auf Google
geschwört, was
die Suchmaschine angeht.
Warum geht das jetzt wieder nicht?
Ah.
Es ist gleich viel weicher.
Start.
Äh.
Okay.
Warum spackt das jetzt so rum?
Warum geht der Fullscreen jetzt nicht mehr?
Was ist das?
Was ist da los?
Hä?
Komisches Ding.
WTF.
Da stand doch da, du musst die Tools
updaten. Ich glaube, das stand nur da.
Guck mal, es ist viel weicher jetzt.
Ich glaube, das stand nur da, weil ich aus hatte.
Okay.
Wenn das rumspackt, ähm.
Dann müssen wir
das von Hand starten. Aber so oft
rebooten tun wir nicht.
Okay, also. Was haben die hier?
Das ist anscheinend ein
komplett eigener
Desktop ohne irgendein...
Oh, das lag.
Okay, 5 FPS.
Wir sind back.
Aber zumindest das Terminal lässt sich einfacher
deutlich ruckelfreier
verschieben.
Gut, das liegt jetzt aber an der
VM. VM und 3D-Beschleunigung ist immer so eine
Sache. An sich...
Ich sag mal...
Ohohoh, das... Alter.
Oh, das laggt.
Kann man hier irgendwie die
3D-Effekte und so was
umschalten?
Effekts?
Also das ist definitiv schon mal
nicht in der Standard-Setting schon mal nicht
für VM geeignet.
Das liegt der, das liegt eindeutig an der VM.
Eindeutig.
Übrigens schon mal gut, wir haben standardmäßig ein Dark-Theme.
Das freut mich schon mal.
Dark-Theme beste.
Muss Dark-Theme.
Ja.
Der Browser an sich fühlt...
4K Fireplace
Linus
Tech-Tipps.
Das ist immer ein gutes Test-Video.
Äh, nicht 43K.
4K Fireplace.
Ich guck mir mal...
Oder 8K ist das, oder?
War das nicht sogar 8K?
8K.
Ah, yes.
YouTube-Werbung.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt, wie sehr...
Geht euch YouTube auch so auf den
Keks mit diesem Overlay?
Also...
Im normalen YouTube kein Problem, im Desktop.
Da hab ich das geblockt.
Aber die YouTube-App auf iOS.
Jedes Mal.
Jedes Mal geht die mir auf den Keks.
Deswegen verwende ich fast bloß noch mein Android-Tablet
dafür jetzt.
Weil mir das so auf den Keks geht.
Auf dem Android-Tablet hat man halt passende YouTube-Apps,
die...
Kein...
Kein Problem sind dann.
Ja, Serious Max, das geht aber nur,
wenn man Jailbreak-Sort hat, oder?
Oder nicht?
Okay, ey, stopp.
Wie? Kein A-Top drauf.
Die Auslastung ist
tatsächlich für ein 4K-Video gar nicht...
Ah, Moment.
Jetzt 4K.
4K sollte nämlich in der VM nicht laufen, richtig?
Nee, macht's auch nicht.
Das geht auch nicht.
Also 4K in der VM,
da brauchst du einfach
GPU-Unterstützung
und das funktioniert halt nicht richtig.
Facebook, selbst 2K,
macht die drei CPU-Kerne.
Die sind fast am Limit.
Funktioniert nicht.
Da warte ich ja persönlich noch drauf,
bis es mal irgendein Hersteller schafft
von Virtualisierungssoftware,
dass man den
Host-Videodecoder von der Grafikkarte
in der VM verwenden kann.
Ja, Serious Max, super.
Super, genau das.
Das kann ich nicht machen.
Ey, das ruckelt immer noch.
Das kann ich nicht machen. Das ist ja ein Handy von der Firma.
Sicher, 50 Billionen ist am Start, neun.
Jetzt erst aufgestanden.
Puh.
Ich würde gerne dieses ganze
dieses ganze
3D-Zeug ausschalten, aber das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay.
Dementsprechend ist
zumindest Solus
Solus-Budgie-Desktop-mäßig
ist für VM-Ware
nicht so gut geil.
Was hat Solus
für einen Paketmanager?
Das passiert wohl
nirgendwo drauf hier.
Das da ist der Paketmanager.
Falls das überhaupt so funktioniert.
Special, special neuer Package-Manager.
EOPK.
Wir gucken mal, in was das
programmiert ist. Also wenn es ein Binary ist,
kriegen wir das nicht raus.
Aber es ist kein Binary, es ist ein Python-Package-Manager.
Ne, dafür ist es ein bisschen kurz.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es ein Python-Programm.
Was ist denn der Sinn der Installation von Solus?
Einfach angucken.
Wir haben hier unsere
Linus-Bewertungskriterien.
Wenn ich die Datei finde.
IHHH C++
Wir haben hier unsere
Linus-Bewertungskriterien.
Wir haben hier unsere Linus-Bewertungskriterien.
Wo wir uns das Ganze mal angucken.
Also bis jetzt ist es ziemlich Standard.
Wir müssen vielleicht die
Huge
Wir müssen vielleicht ein bisschen größere Font
Im Terminal machen.
Ist das ein Gnome-Terminal?
Oder ist das was eigenes?
Ja, das ist ein Gnome-Terminal.
Er sieht, wollte ich gerade sagen,
Er sieht nämlich original aus wie ein Gnome-Terminal.
So, dann stellen wir erstmal die Schriftart um.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich in der Lage wäre,
rauszufinden, wie man hier die Schriftart umstellt.
Leute, wo ist die?
Ah, hier! Custom Font.
Hack.
Ohhhhh!
Das ist ein Pluspunkt.
Meine Lieblingsschriftart ist vorinstalliert.
Ich bin begeistert.
So muss das sein.
So muss das sein. Sehr gut.
Perfekt.
Sehr gut.
Das ist schon mal Pluspunkt bei mir.
Mahatma Gandhi.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und Tschüss.
Huge. Huge Sub.
Und jetzt müssen wir auch mal den Hintergrund ausstellen.
Gibt es jemand von euch,
meine Frage, ich weiß, dass es Geschmack hat,
benutzt ihr transparenten Terminal-Hintergrund?
Ich mag's nicht.
Ich mag's nicht so.
Weil das ziemlich anstrengend ist,
drauf zu gucken.
So ist viel angenehmer drauf zu gucken.
Also ne, so finde ich es viel angenehmer drauf zu gucken,
als so.
Ne, ja.
Nur ganz leicht, also quasi
so.
Leicht Blur.
Okay, ich sehe, es ist so ziemlich 50-50.
Also ich mag
Terminal-Transparenz mag ich nicht.
Nicht meins.
Okay, aber das gefällt mir
vorinstalliert schon mal ganz gut.
Wie aktuell?
Das ist jetzt wirklich eine spannende Frage, weil
die setzen nirgendwo drauf auf
bei Solos.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie aktuell
die Pakete sind. Wie durchsucht man hier was?
Search.
Und jetzt sag mal, wie ist Code?
Ist das dabei?
Oh, tatsächlich.
Hm.
Und wie lässt man sich jetzt die Version anzeigen?
Info vielleicht?
Oh, das ist,
das ist, glaube ich, sogar ziemlich aktuell.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich aktuell.
Ja, ziemlich aktuell.
Aktuell ist, äh,
ja, das ist gut.
Kann man sich nicht beschwerten, ist in Ordnung.
EOP, warum
warum EOPK?
Warum EOPK?
Solos ist
warum EOPK?
Install.
Alias abgleich EOPK.
Warum EOPK? Ich kann mir da überhaupt keinen Reim drauf machen.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
Man, EOPK. Solos Package Manager.
Ah, so.
Wobei, wo kommt das E her?
Das O könnte ich mir noch aus Solos
zusammen reimen, aber
warum E?
Weiß man nicht genau.
Richtige
Boomer-Mucke, ja.
Muss so sein.
Extra Packages,
Package Dependencies.
Okay, was
installiert er hier standardmäßig noch dabei?
Wenn ich hier das Code installiere.
Git, okay.
LibUV, Node.js. Ich glaub, das braucht man. Ohne Git's nicht.
Weil, weil Elektronen,
Elektronengedöns.
Perl? Perl?
Oh Mann, vielleicht ist das für den Build?
Was ist? Hm.
Ist Solos eher so
eine Geschichte mit
fertigen Paketen mit Binarys
drinne? Oder bildet
der mir das jetzt irgendwie?
Schauen wir mal. Okay, naja.
Für ein eigenes Build ist das alles
viel zu schnell.
Der gefällt mir aber. Der gefällt mir.
Das hat irgendwie was.
Ist auch schön zu bedienen, alles.
Das gefällt mir
gut bis jetzt.
0w, kekw.
Schön, schön.
Ähm.
Gnome MPV.
Okay, das ist Media Player.
Kann der
YouTube Zeug abspielen?
Kann der YouTube Zeug abspielen?
Guck mal mal.
YouTube.
Oh! Wow!
Der Default Media Player
kann, kann, kann YouTube abspielen.
Ist gar nicht schlecht.
Kann der Twitch abspielen?
Okay, meine CPU Leistung
geht ein bisschen in die Knie. Dadurch,
dass ich jetzt gerade ein 8K Video laufen hab,
kann man hier vielleicht die Settings umstellen?
Videotrack?
Ja.
Das ist jetzt 8K.
8K Videotrack ist ein bisschen zu hart für den Rechner hier.
Mal ausmachen. Twitch.
Twitch. Oblos. Kann der Twitch
abspielen, standardmäßig?
Das wär richtig cool.
Open.
Oh! Leute!
Guckt mal hier!
Wir können uns selbst zugucken
im Media Player.
Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich echt cool,
dass das Ding
standardmäßig Twitch und YouTube abspielen kann.
Das gibt schon mal Pluspunkte.
Gut.
Ist halt MP4...
Jaja, ich hab's schon gesehen.
Ja, in der 4M hat's leider keine Hardware Acceleration.
Weil halt in der 4M
gibt's keinen Hardware Decoder.
Und, ja.
Ich muss Maximilian
da mal wahllos recht geben.
Es ist eine absolute Zumutung,
dass auch unter Linux Desktop,
also sprich nicht in der 4M,
so auf richtige Hardware,
Videoplayback im Browser
zum größten Teil nicht Hardware Accelerated ist.
Das ist einfach lächerlich im Jahr 2020.
Kompletter Witz, ja.
Ist i3 im Package Manager
drin mit Gaps?
Du meinst hier?
Eher nicht.
Ist ja in Manjaro
automatisch ist es ja auch nur User Repo mit Gaps.
Wobei,
bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Es könnte sogar mittlerweile in Extras
drin sein.
Ja, DHM Videos kannst du klicken.
DHM Videos
kannst du eh generell unter Linux
teilen.
Wobei ich glaube, ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube Amazon geht im Chrome.
Ja, i3.
Die Frage ist, ob i3 Gaps drin ist.
Machen wir mal i3.
Moin Roffel1436
Früher hat man noch
Roffel gesagt.
Das ist komplett out. Heute sagt man
KekW.
Oder KekW
wie die sagen.
Ok, i3 ist dabei.
Allerdings
kein i3 mit Gaps.
Oh, hoho, guck mal Leute.
Ist sogar i3 Gaps
standardmäßig drin.
Big Brain Package Maintainer
wie es aussieht bei Solos.
Maintainer, das hast du doch nur gefragt,
weil du genau wusstest, dass es drin ist.
Oder gibst du zu?
Das ist ja schon mal gut, dass es drin ist.
Mir gefällt es
bis jetzt echt gut.
Askiquarium, oh ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Achso, kann das über Wildcard
searches? Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht drin.
Das Askiquarium
ist nicht drin.
Hast du dir mal den Editor Brackets angeschaut?
Ja, vor Jahren mal.
Weil ich dieses
Live HTML Editing Feature
ganz cool fand.
Aber ist das Ding nicht ziemlich tot mittlerweile?
Hat selbst nicht Adobe den Kram
Wobei,
wie spricht man
das eigentlich richtig aus, Leute?
Jetzt mal Real Talk.
Jetzt mal Spaß
beiseite.
Heißt das Adobe oder Adobe?
Sekunde.
Aussprache Adobe.
Adobe.
Slow.
Adobe. Alles klar.
Okay.
Adobe.
Adobe. Okay, man spricht es
mit I aus. Alles klar.
Jetzt müssen wir Bescheid.
Ich habe auf, wie ich
klein war, Baby Hühnchen
genau bei mir. Ich habe früher
gesagt Adobe. Adobe.
Ah.
Oder Adobe oder so.
hab ich früher gesagt.
Danach hab ich festgestellt.
Moment.
Das ist ein englisches Wort.
Das hab ich gesagt Adobe.
Und irgendwann bin ich draufgekommen.
Es heißt Adobe.
Und noch mal eine Frage.
S-C-S-I.
oder S-C-S-I
oder Scasy?
Eigentlich ist das nicht mehr
Ich meine, immerhin, in SATA lebt es weiter, ja.
SCS.
Move Workspace.
Shift Super End.
Ah ja, hier sind wir jetzt.
Okay.
Und Shift Super Post 1.
Ach, eigentlich geht das sogar.
Ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Super Page, dann habe ich schon alles ausprobiert.
Das geht anscheinend nicht, weil meine Workspaces sind links und rechts und nicht...
Ah ja, geht, geht.
Die meisten Leute brauchen wahrscheinlich eh nur zwei.
Ich brauche drei.
Mindestens.
Also eigentlich habe ich sieben Stück.
Eigentlich habe ich sieben Workspaces.
Ich habe, also auf der Arbeit verwende ich auch alle sieben.
Ich habe es meistens so, ich hoffe mal, dass ich das Gericht aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
Also ich habe auf dem ersten Desktop, habe ich Chrome immer auf.
Auf dem zweiten Desktop habe ich Terminal immer auf.
Auf dem fünften habe ich mein RDP auf irgendeine komische Windows-VM, die ich brauche.
Auf dem dritten habe ich meistens Programmierzeug auf.
Auf dem vierten habe ich Chat, Messenger auf.
Auf dem siebten...
Das dürfen wir jetzt keinem verraten, Leute.
Chat.
Psst, müsst ihr ruhig sein, Chat.
Also, Achtung.
Auf dem siebten Desktop.
Habe ich den Firefox mit Discord auf.
Und YouTube und Twitter, da gucke ich ab und zu mal rein.
Und der sechste ist für irgendwie alle möglichen Sachen.
Ja, was meint ihr, warum ich auf der Arbeit so viel Twitter...
Also, ich weiß nicht, so viel.
Ich tue da gar nicht, ich setze da gar nicht zwei Tweets am Tag ab, wenn irgendwas Interessantes passiert.
Das mache ich nicht vom Smartphone, ich mache einfach Twitter halt auf dem siebten Desktop auf.
Ist nicht verboten.
Ist erlaubt, muss man sagen.
Ich mache das jetzt nicht irgendwie top secret, sodass es keiner merkt, weil es verboten wäre.
Das ist erlaubt.
Aber ich habe es halt nicht ganz vorne.
Ich will jetzt nicht, dass das Erste, was man sieht, ist bei mir.
Ich nehme halt Firefox mit Twitter auf oder so.
Nee, so hat bei uns auch kaum einer Probleme mit.
Ich meine, man macht ja trotzdem was.
Es ist ja eh komplett bescheuert, die Annahme.
Ich weiß, dass das in manchen Firmen so ist.
Aber die Annahme...
Dass Mitarbeiter in der Zeit, wo sie mal kurz auf YouTube was gucken oder auf Twitch was nachgucken
oder sich auf Facebook ihre Messages lesen oder sonst was,
dass die halt dann quasi der Firma Arbeitszeit stehlen würden oder so, das ist ein kompletter Blödsinn.
In der Zwischenzeit, wo die das machen, würden die ansonsten nichts arbeiten.
Weil es ist, weil du einfach mal ab und zu fünf Minuten dich erholen musst
oder fünf Minuten dich mal ablenken musst, irgendwie ein bisschen was anderes machen.
Das ist vollkommen legitim und sorgt unterm Strich eigentlich nur dafür,
dass die Leute sogar mehr arbeiten.
Als wenn sie das nicht dürften.
Meine Ansicht bei der Sache.
NiceToastBro, Stufe 1, fünf Monate in Folge.
Huge.
Sub.
Dankeschön.
Ist deine Aussage, dass YouTube-Videos mit 48 FPS eine viel höhere Bitrate haben, noch valid?
Weil du letztens den 40 FPS hochgeladen hast.
Äh...
Ja, bei 1080p ist das noch so.
Wenn ich Videos 720p oder 1080p hochlade?
Dann würde ich die auf YouTube 30 besser, also qualitativ mit 30 FPS sind sie besser.
Mit 48 sind sie halt deutlich flüssiger und besser als mit 40 FPS.
Weil 1080p und vor allem 720p hat bei YouTube halt eine absolut miese Bitrate.
Wenn man das macht wie ich in den letzten Videos und die in 1440p hochlädt,
dann kann man sie mit 60 FPS hochladen, weil man dann genug Bandbreite bekommt bei YouTube.
Allerdings sehen sie natürlich trotzdem...
Wenn sie sich jemand mit niedrigerer Bandbreite anguckt, kacke aus.
Deswegen kann ich euch auch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr YouTube-Videos guckt und nur einen 1080p Bildschirm habt,
guckt die Videos trotzdem in 1440p an.
Was ist das denn für ein Eierjahr-Terminal-Theme?
Keine Ahnung, das ist Default.
Das ist Default Solos Terminal Theme.
Das sieht so aus.
So, okay, was wollte man als nächstes gucken?
Irgendwie gesagt, Optic Look & Feel finde ich sehr gut bis jetzt.
Äh, für 4M ist es nicht.
Genauso wie Performance und Responsiveness ich jetzt nicht fairerweise, also nicht fair beurteilen kann,
weil es ist halt eindeutig nicht dafür ausgelegt in der 4M zu laufen mit, äh, das braucht 3D-Beschleunigung.
Die hat in der 4M mehr schlecht als recht funktioniert.
Was für eine Schelte, das ist wahrscheinlich Bash, gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus, ja.
Es hat eigentlich, mir fällt keine Distribution ein, die Default nicht Bash verwendet.
Fällt euch einer ein?
Bash ist einfach mittlerweile überall.
Ubuntu hat standardmäßig auch Bash.
Das einzige, wo Ubuntu Dash verwendet, ist, ähm, wenn du Skripts ausführst, die explizit auf BIN-SH gehen.
Die interaktive Shell auf Ubuntu-Server ist auch Bash.
Z, äh, okay, ich kenne keine Distribution, doch, doch, ich fällt mir, doch, mir fällt einer ein.
Äh, Grimmel hat ZSH verwendet eine ganze Weile hier.
Grimmel Linux Live-CD.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch gibt.
Grimmel.
Okay, anscheinend.
Anscheinend gibt es das immer noch.
Grimmel.
Ähm, die haben ZSH als Default verwendet, als Live-CD, aber ansonsten fällt mir nichts ein.
BIN-SH zeigt auf Dash, sag ich doch.
Junge, die Webseite ist richtig oldschool, ja.
Allerdings, ähm, darf man das in dem Fall tatsächlich nicht nach der Webseite beurteilen.
Ich finde, es ist eine der besten Live-Distributionen, die es gibt.
Auch wenn die Webseite echt aussieht wie, ja, wie 2003.
Dafür kann man wahrscheinlich den Source-Code, ja, das hat garantiert einer von Hand geschrieben.
Das sieht einfach so oldschool aus.
Okay, was, was, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Pakete.
Match-Up-Template.
VS-Code ist halbwegs aktuell, haben wir ausprobiert.
Firefox und Chrome, stimmt.
Was, was haben wir da zu bieten?
EO-PK.
Gibt es für Solos Custom-Repos?
Wird mich mal interessieren.
Gibt es so extra Third-Party-Packages?
Ah, mit, okay, mit Snaps wollen sie das jetzt machen.
Okay.
Das heißt, das heißt, die haben im Package-Manager Snaps drinne?
Was, Krimmel.org ist bei euch gehostet?
Wie gesagt, das ist eine Live-Distribution, die kann ich nur empfehlen.
Die, von der Webseite darf man sich nicht abschrecken lassen, die ist ziemlich gut.
Snap, okay, was haben wir denn hier für einen Snap?
Durchsuchen wir mal.
Ob da schon Snaps drin sind?
Ich weiß nicht, ob da Snaps drinne sind.
Third-Party, hier.
Arduino, ah, ne, Android Studios dabei, oh Gott, Flash, Leute, gehen wir fort, please.
Guckt mal, ob es Sol gibt, das ist ein Fork von EO-PK, Moment, Moment, warum brauche ich für den offiziellen Package-Manager einen Fork?
Was ist denn das?
Gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Was haben die sonst noch hier?
Git-Kraken?
Sieht aus wie ein Git-Frontend.
Nur Noobs verwenden Git-Frontends.
Kommando-Zeile, einzig wahre, was Git-Bedienung angeht.
Ernst gemeint jetzt.
Wenn ich unsere Java-Entwickler auf der Arbeit immer sehe, wie sie in Eclipse und irgendwelchen anderen IDEs ihr Git-Zeug zusammenklicken, da ist es wirklich PP-Gateim angesagt.
Okay, wir können Chrome nachinstallieren?
Haben wir Chromium zu bieten?
Chromium?
FFM-Pack? Chromium? Was?
Chromiums FFM-Pack for Chromium-based Browsers.
Moment, es ist Chromiums FFM-Pack for Chromium... What?
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Ähm, aber Chromium gibt es anscheinend nicht, aber Chromium gibt es zu installieren.
Checkboxen setzen, statt 10 Dateipfeile einzutippen. Ist schon Big Brain.
Ich weiß nicht, worauf dich beziehst.
Winklers 2, Dankeschön. Vier Monate. Huge Brain, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh, gar kein Prime. Richtig echter.
Wahnsinn.
Onashin Gikuru, auch am Start. Sieben Monate schon.
Geht's aufwärts. Huge. Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs, Freunde.
Äh, bei Git vs. Git-Gui... Achso, ja, da hast du recht.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man Git mit einem Gui verwandelt.
Moment, das leuchtet mich überhaupt nicht ein.
Git-CLI, Beste.
Git über die Kommandozeile hat ein paar merkwürdige Dinger drinne.
Ja, manchmal ist die Frage, schreibt man Remote vorne hin mit einem Leerzeichen dazwischen.
Manchmal schreibt man das Remote da hinten hin mit einem Slash dazwischen.
Äh, es ist nicht... Also, Git-Kommandozeilenbedienung ist auch nicht so komplett das Gelbe vom Ei.
Aber man kann damit wenigstens alles machen.
Und wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat, will man das nicht über den Gui verwenden.
Alle Leute, die Git über den Gui verwenden, sind nur zu faul gewesen.
Bisher waren ein bisschen die Kommandozeilenbefehle für zu lernen.
Keiner an sich nach.
Und das Einzige, wofür wirklich ein Git-Gui ganz schön ist, wenn man einen History-Craft will.
Weil das sieht in der Kommandozeile halt nicht so hoch aufgelöst auf.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich generiere mir zweimal im Jahr oder so einen History-Craft.
Das war's. Braucht man eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Oh, guck mal! Wir haben sogar Jetbrain-Zeugs drinne.
Bigbrain, Jetbrain. Gibt's die Toolbox?
Gibt's die Jetbrain-Toolbox?
Jetbrains.
Kotlin ist auch dabei.
Gibt's die Toolbox? Das wär natürlich, äh, huge.
Guck mal! Man kann sogar Rider und Rubimein und Gedulds alles installieren.
Oh, das find ich, das find ich cool.
Das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir gut.
Dass, dass die, dass so Sachen auch dabei sind.
Meint ihr, das ist ein Snap?
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob das ein Snap ist?
Schau mal, installieren wir mal Rider.
Installieren wir mal. So, Rubimein, braun, Skype.
Gehen wir mal fort. Slack, Spotify.
Leute, wir haben auf der Arbeit jetzt, seit letzter, letzter Woche, haben wir Microsoft Teams am Start.
Slack ist ja zum Glück, der Kelch ist an uns vorübergegangen.
Ähm, dafür mussten wir uns die letzten zwei Jahre mit Skype oder die letzten drei Jahre mit Skype for Business rumschlagen.
Und ich kann euch sagen, Skype for Business ist mit Abstand der räudigste Messenger, den ihr je gesehen habt.
Skype for Business kann beispielsweise, das ist ein Messenger wohlgemerkt, ja.
Kann beispielsweise keine Nachrichten an Leute schicken, die offline sind.
Von einem normalen, ähm, Messenger würde man ja erwarten, wenn man offline ist, bekommt man eine Message, geht online, kriegt man die Message.
Nicht so bei Skype for Business. Das kriegt man dann als Mail zugestellt und, ähm, in diesen Mail-Ordner, der irgendwie sich, sich verpasste, äh, irgendwie verpasste, aufgezeichnete Unterhaltung nennt.
Das ist so ein typischer, typischer, ähm, Microsoft-Name, verpasste, aufgezeichnete Unterhaltung.
Ähm, da guckt nie jemand rein.
Ja, auch Nachrichten, die länger sind als eine gewisse Zeil, äh, Zeilenanzahl kann Skype for Business nicht.
Skype for Business ist absoluter Dreck.
Ich hab so viele Nachrichten nicht gesehen, weil, weil mir jemand auf, auf Skype for Business geschrieben hat.
Und ich hab Skype for Business ja eh schon ignoriert, weil ich hab das auf meiner Windows vor allem auf der Arbeit laufen, da guck ich halt einfach nicht rein.
Und Teams ist relativ gut, muss ich sagen.
Also Teams ist ganz okay.
Ähm, ich mein, Teams ist ein bisschen, ein bisschen so wie Skype für Arme, äh, was, was laber ich, wie Discord für Arme.
Also, es kann halt viel weniger als Discord, aber dafür ist es halt Business, ja.
Sag mal, was, was, was installiert der da eigentlich, fünf Stunden?
Okay, der, der macht da auch Sachen.
Der macht da Dinge im Hintergrund.
Wir, wir lassen ihn, wir lassen ihn mal weiter.
Wir lassen ihn mal installieren.
Und Teams ist Slack für Arme, ja, das kann, kann schon sein.
Ähm, aber ich bin froh, dass, ähm, Slack an uns vorübergegangen ist.
Gar nicht mal, weil ich so extrem was gegen Slack habe.
Aber ich weiß, dass die ganzen Leute, die sich um, um so, so, so Tool-Geschichten bei uns kümmern, ähm, die können nur Microsoft-Zeug und Atlassian-Zeug.
Das können die nicht.
Deswegen ist gut, dass sie Teams genommen haben.
Das ist nämlich wenigstens was, was die, was die auf die Reihe bekommen.
Was, was auch wieder ganz, eine Sache, die mir bei Teams schon gleich auf den Keks gegangen ist, direkt nachdem, haben wir es heute nochmal hier?
Eine Sache direkt nachdem es installiert wurde bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Also ein, ein Riesenvorteil, schon mal.
Ähm, es gibt einen Native Linux-Client für Teams.
Das ist schon mal huge.
Wahrscheinlich ist es auch nur Elektron, ja.
Aber es gibt einen Native.
Native, in Anführungsstrichen, Linux-Client.
Es gibt einen Linux-Client im Browser halt, in dem Extra-Fenster.
Ähm, die, eine Sache, die mir aber schon gleich auf den Keks gegangen ist, ist die sehr merkwürdige, ähm, Ticketsystem-Integration.
Ich wollte für unseren Channel, wollte ich unser, unser Hira linken.
Und das ging nur mit der Hira Cloud-Version.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, wozu soll ich denn die Hira Cloud, äh, äh, äh, ne, Cloud-Version linken.
Wir haben ne lokale Installation.
Der PP-Gar.
Okay, jetzt gehen wir mal auf Desktop 3, äh, auf, auf Desktop 2.
Und starten mal Rider.
Es ist auch standardmäßig direkt gleich drinnen.
Äh, man muss da nicht irgendwie was refreshen oder so, finde ich gut.
Äh, Teams kann keine halbwegs funktionieren Code-Formatting-Snippets.
Muss ich mal am Montag ausprobieren.
Keine Settings importieren.
Confirm.
Now, wir senden nix.
Äh, Dark Theme, wunderbar.
Visual Studio, ab, ab, ab.
Äh, nein, haben wir doch schon.
Haben wir doch schon.
Environment, äh, ja, ist gut.
Natürlich blöd, ist nicht installiert.
Ah, gibt es, gibt es .NET Core zum Installieren?
Das, das probieren wir doch gleich mal aus.
Gibt es .NET Core?
Search.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Core.
Hm.
Nach was könnte ich da suchen?
Nach was könnte ich da suchen, da ich das finde?
Core Host oder so?
Core SDK?
Hm.
Immer eine glorreiche Idee.
.NET?
Search.
Vielleicht ist es nicht dabei.
.NET Solos.
Äh.
Okay, ich glaube, wir sind im Issue Tracker gelandet.
Okay, ist es jetzt da drin oder nicht?
Ah, Snap.
Okay, man muss es wohl über Snap machen anscheinend.
Obwohl, eigentlich, ups, falsch, falsch, Desktop gewechselt, das ist eigentlich auch nicht so wild.
Ähm, dann installieren wir das Ganze jetzt mal über Snap.
Ist das drauf?
Snap.
List.
Install.
.NET.
Einfach nur so?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Snap.
Was, was, was habe ich jetzt schon wieder leaked, Leute?
Was habe ich jetzt schon wieder, wow.
Wrong case.
Was habe ich jetzt schon wieder leaked, Leute?
Ich leake hier ja laufend irgendwas.
Direkt gehackt.
Fuck.
.NET Snap.
Uhrzeit liegt.
Oh, shit.
Monka S.
Okay, man kann einfach hier .NET SDK installieren.
Kann man nicht einfach Snap install .NET machen?
Geht doch bestimmt auch.
Ha.
Wie installiert man das?
Habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Snap.
Install.
.NET.
Das brauchen wir nämlich für, für Rider brauchen wir das.
.NET minus SDK?
Okay.
Warum?
Weil man mit einer Kommandozeile, die ich ausführen kann.
.NET Core?
Wie installiere ich das?
Install.
Ah, so.
Das ist ja auch kompliziert gemacht, oder?
Okay, dann muss man das schon mal als Root machen.
Schon mal merkwürdig.
Warum muss ich das als Root machen?
Snap.
Nipp, schnapp.
Von Kommandozeilen hält Microsoft nicht viel.
Das kann man mittlerweile gar nicht mehr sagen.
Okay, das muss man wahrscheinlich nachher extra konfigurieren.
Ich beende das noch mal und guck mal.
Oh, nee.
Geh, geh, geh weg.
Kannst du, kannst du ausgehen?
Alter, ich will nicht.
Kill X.
Wie führt man hier Programme aus?
Execute irgendwas.
Run.
Gibt's was?
Kill X.
Nee, X kill.
X kill.
Ja, fuck geht nicht.
Das kann man mittlerweile gar nicht mehr sagen.
X.
Warum?
Warum kann ich hier kein Fenster nix machen?
Das geht.
Das funktioniert, ja.
Aber trotzdem.
Ups.
Ah, wie der Desktop liegt, Leute.
Ha.
Wer sich gedacht hat, dass das funktioniert.
Warum kann ich kein Kill X machen?
Na gut.
Dann nicht.
Evaluate for free.
Evaluate.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Continue.
Okay.
Jetzt konfigurieren wir mal .NET Settings.
Na, gucken wir mal, ob das, ob das funktioniert.
Äh.
Hier. Irgendwo war das drunter, ne?
Runtime.
Toolset ist übelst versteckt.
Hier, er hat's, er hat's sogar erkannt.
Mono brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, guck mal, er hat's, er hat's doch schon erkannt.
Snap.
Current.net.
Save.
Sehr gut.
New solution.
Probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus, ob's prinzipiell funktioniert.
Create.
Leaked.
Fuck.
Schon wieder leaked.
Ja, tatsächlich funktioniert alles dabei.
Bin begeistert.
Solos, das habt ihr gut gemacht.
Gucken, ob's runt.
Geiler, geiler Satz.
Nicht, also Leute, wir schauen mal, ob's runt jetzt, ja?
Hello world.
Das find ich gut.
Find ich, find ich echt nicht schlecht.
Bis jetzt.
Gefällt mir, gefällt mir.
Also, ich muss sagen, ähm.
Wir hatten ja bisher von allen, ähm.
Wie kommt man nochmal in die Settings?
Keyboard shortcuts.
Kann man Kommandos runnen?
Äh, also bisher von allen Desktop-Distributions.
Die wir bisher ausprobiert haben.
Muss ich sagen.
Ähm, das meiste war Crap.
Ganz gut gefallen haben wir, hatten wir für totale Noobs.
Elementary OS fand ich ganz gut.
Und Deep in Linux, wenn man damit klarkommt, dass es das China Linux ist, war auch ganz gut.
Für totale Noobs.
Solos, würd ich sagen, ist nicht unbedingt für totale Noobs.
Ähm.
Solos ist eher was für...
Entwickler vielleicht.
Für Leute, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben.
Aber trotzdem gerne was ordentlich vorkonfiguriertes haben wollen, bis jetzt.
Sieht's für mich so aus, ja.
Was ich ganz gut finde.
So, und wie kann man, gibt es hier nen Run-Command?
Run.
Ah, Alt-F2.
Hab ich doch gemacht.
Ja, hab ich doch, hab ich doch gemacht.
Problem ist nur, ähm.
Ja gut, ist klar.
Gut.
Ah, wir haben ja auch Sounds.
Hab ich ja ganz vergessen, ja.
Ähm.
Allerdings wirklich schön ist das nicht, oder?
Ne.
So, okay, was gucken wir als nächstes?
Was brauchen wir als nächstes hier?
Firefox Chrome.
Ah, gibt es, gibt es bei Chrome.
Bei Chrome gibt es nicht den Fork mit, mit Videobeschleunigung, anscheinend.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Das wär natürlich richtig Premium.
Wenn es bei Chrome das gäbe.
Mit, ähm.
Mit Videobeschleunigung.
Das wäre natürlich richtig cool.
Aber gibt es anscheinend nicht.
Oder denke ich mal nicht, dass es das Chrome gibt mit.
Mit Videobeschleunigung.
Ne, eher nicht.
Gibt es den eigentlich als Snap?
Hm.
Vielleicht.
Allerdings muss man das Snap auf jeden Fall extra konfigurieren, dass es Zugriff auf die Grafikkarte, Grafikencoder Funktion hat.
Ähm.
Security Software Start Party.
Na, was hatten die sonst noch so?
Endpass.
Habe ich mal eine Weile verwendet.
Ähm.
So einen Monat oder so.
Als Passwortmanager für unsichere Dinger, die ich einfach nicht plaintext hinschreiben wollte.
Aber nachdem die sich damals so geziert haben, was ihr Security Audit angeht, habe ich den nie wieder verwendet danach.
Hast du dich mittlerweile mal mit ETS beschäftigt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Meine Kohle liegt immer noch einfach so rum.
Und das sackt.
Money Dance.
Hat der auch den Swag?
Ocean Audio.
Fast Cross Platform Audio Editor.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Ocean...
Audio.
Ne, nicht Au...
Ne, wie hieß das Ding?
O...
Das ist immer wichtig zu wissen, was für Entwicklerwerkzeuge dabei sind, weil ich behaupte mal, dass einfach viele Leute die Linux nicht einfach so als Hobby-Desktop-Betriebssystem verwenden, dass die eben entwickeln da drauf.
Und deswegen ist wichtig zu gucken, was 4.11, ich glaube das ist halbwegs aktuell, ja, das ist halbwegs aktuell, ja, passt, das ist aktuelle.
Cute Creator, Install, Following Dependencies, das ist egal, was ich hier anklicke, wahrscheinlich ist das alles, Install, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, welche Node.js-Version ist dabei?
Gucken wir mal, hat er eben schon installiert, ach nee, da müssen wir machen Info, Info, 12.141.
Ist das aktuell? Ist LTS, ja gut, das ist ja, ich sag in Ordnung, dass man da eine LTS-Version für nimmt.
Wisst ihr, was ich übrigens mal ausprobieren möchte, einen der nächsten Streams, hier, wie heißt das, Deno oder so?
GitHub Deno, das ist ein, ich weiß nicht, ob man das wirklich Node.js-Konkurrenz nennen kann.
Es ist von dem ursprünglichen Node.js-Gründer, einer der Mitglieder.
Node.js-Gründer von Node.js, eine neue JavaScript-Runtime für den Desktop.
Allerdings Runtime, muss man auch sagen, es ist V8 von Chrome, also Google V8, im Endeffekt drunter.
Allerdings ist TypeScript eingebaut und noch ein paar andere coole Sachen.
Ich bin mir noch recht unschlüssig, wofür man das eigentlich braucht.
Aber 44.000 GitHub-Sterne spricht für sich, dass es nicht ganz so unsinnig sein kann.
Halbkorn, Mathe.
Welche Klasse oder studierst du?
Was ist gerade angesagt?
Mathe.
Ist doch mit Rust geschrieben.
Ja, teilweise, ja, ist es.
Okay, gehen wir mal hier auf den nächsten Desktop und schauen wir mal, ob der Qt-Creator richtig funktioniert.
Projects, New Projects, Qt-Widget-Application.
Ne, wir machen keine Qt-Widget-Application.
Ja, das sind aber noch die falschen.
Das sind die richtigen Vorlagen.
Choose.
Next.
Aktuelles Qt ist drauf.
Finish.
Wow, jetzt geht es aber ab, was?
Don't show.
Okay, der Qt-Creator ist schon mal grausam vorkonfiguriert.
Ich meine, schwarz auf dunkel.
Das kann man nur nicht erkennen.
Ja, Halbkorn, viel Glück bei der Arbeit.
Und das Bild geht auch nicht.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht gut.
Ähm, okay.
Das ist schon mal nicht gut vorkonfiguriert, weil es geht nicht.
Standardmäßig ist es kaputt.
Aber wahrscheinlich lässt sich es relativ easy fixen.
Aber machen wir jetzt nicht.
Remove.
Die Frage ist jetzt, hat der auch alles jetzt removed, wenn ich es hier remove?
Das müssen wir mal nachgucken.
Qt, äh, search.
Ha, wie sieht man, ob was installiert ist?
Info?
Sieht man, ob es hier installiert ist oder nicht?
Seht ihr irgendwo eine Anzeige, ob das Paket aktuell installiert ist oder nicht?
Wo sehe ich, ob das Paket installiert ist, wenn ich es mir anzeigen lasse?
Mal gucken, ob der jetzt nämlich auch die Abhängigkeiten alle wieder aufgeräumt hat.
Ne, hat er nicht.
Hat er nicht.
Er hat den Kram drauf.
Na gut, das ist natürlich nicht so schön.
Dann hat man ganz viel unsinnige Pakete nach und nach auf dem System drauf,
weil man ein paar Sachen installiert hat und wieder runtergeworfen hat.
Das ist immer doof.
Das finde ich an Arch Linux echt ganz praktisch,
dass man die meisten Pakete ziemlich rückstandslos wieder los wird.
Dafür sind natürlich so Sachen wie Snap und Flatpak und Containergeschichten ganz gut.
Danach ist die Anwendung einfach weg.
Oh, die Peppers sind auch weg.
Ah, ähm, nochmal neu.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, Default, Default.
Okay, Jetbrains Toolbox war nicht dabei, ist Light IDE dabei?
Das führt, ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Go-Noob-Zeug braucht keiner.
Genau, wir gucken, wir gucken mal, was, was für eine Go-Version drauf ist.
Das ist auch ganz interessant.
EOPK, Search, Search, jetzt ist die Frage, Go oder Golang?
Golang.
Info.
Welche Version?
1, 1, 3, 7.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, legit kein Plan, was gerade für eine Go-Version aktuell ist.
Die hier.
Sehr gut.
Also Go ist die allerneueste Version drinnen.
Was ich noch nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt habe,
ist Solos Rolling Release.
Ist das Rolling oder ist das so ein Zwischending?
Zwischen manchen Sachen Rolling?
Ach hier.
Okay, es ist Rolling Release.
Curated Rolling?
Ah, okay.
Dann ist es, dann ist es so ein halbes Roll.
Also sprich, es ist nicht automatisch quasi auf Teufel komm raus, Bleeding Edge.
Man muss aber nicht, also man muss nicht, nicht neu installieren im Endeffekt und keine Upgrades machen.
Man kriegt immer neue Versionen.
Allerdings, es ist, es wird sich angeguckt, bevor es eine neue Version gibt.
Warum tust du dir denn Solos an?
Ich finde es bis jetzt nicht schlecht.
Also ich muss sagen, von den Sachen, die wir bisher ausprobiert haben, ist das,
von dem, wie ich, wie sich das für mich jetzt so darstellt, eines der besten, die wir ausprobiert haben bisher.
Version 1, 3, 3, 7.
Oh, das ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Version.
Da fehlt, fehlt noch was.
Ob die Schnellbar-Sicherheits-Patches sind?
Oh, das, das ist eine gute Idee.
Gab es, gab es letztens...
Gibt es wieder eine Sudo-Geschichte?
Und die letzte Sudo-Geschichte ist ein halbes Jahr, Alter, an die ich mich erinnern kann.
Was ist die richtige...
Sudo.
Ne.
Jetzt aktuell, okay.
Am 31.01. ist das.
Die Sudo-Version 1, 8, 1 abgesichert.
Okay, die haben die neueste.
Passt.
Die haben 1, 8, 3, 1.
Also, da sind sie zumindest sicherheitstechnisch ganz, ganz gut dabei.
Ach, ja, ich sehe es.
Ich sehe es gerade wieder, dass es jetzt auch anscheinend was bei Sudo gab.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Das letzte Sudo, die letzte Sudo-Sicherheitslücke, an die ich mich erinnern kann, die ist irgendwie ein halbes Jahr oder so her.
Das war die, wo du an Sudo...
Was war das nochmal?
Was musste man hinten dranhängen?
Man musste einfach nur was hinten dranhängen und hatte Hutrecht.
War total für den Arsch.
Haben wir, glaube ich, sogar im Stream ausprobiert.
Die Raute, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Was?
Wir haben es im Stream ausprobiert.
Und es hat funktioniert.
Und es war total...
It's AF war das, da Hutrechte zu bekommen.
Also, das ist alles halbwegs aktuell.
Was gucken wir nochmal?
Mal gucken, was für eine Ruby-Version drauf ist.
Ich bin ja immer noch alter Ruby-Fan.
Auch wenn ich in letzter Zeit wenig Grund habe, was mit Ruby zu machen.
Ruby?
Welt...
Wo?
Ah, hier.
Ach, man muss Info machen.
Da muss ich mich immer noch dran gewöhnen.
Info.
265, ich glaube, das ist ziemlich aktuell.
Node.js haben wir geguckt.
.NET Core war nicht drin, nur als Snap.
Was für eine Docker-Version dabei ist?
Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Wir gucken erstmal, was für eine Python-Version dabei ist.
27...
What?
27?
Heißt das vielleicht Python 3?
Ah, ja.
Okay.
Leute, 369 Python, ist das halbwegs aktuell?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube, das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Copy-Paste geht irgendwie nicht.
Docker?
Was haben wir für eine Docker-Version dabei?
Die ist, ich glaube, auch ganz okay.
Ist das nicht sogar die aktuelle?
Docker versteckt ihre Version immer so.
Brauche ich immer eine Weile, die zu finden.
19035.
Ja, ist die aktuelle.
So.
Dann installieren wir mal eine Runde Docker-Compose.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir einen Docker-Container oder so starten können.
Als Abhängigkeit installieren wir Docker-Compose auch Docker mit, so wie das sein sollte.
Docker-Compose, Who-Am-I, Example.
Probieren einfach mal den billig, äh, den Noob-Test aus, ja.
Einfach diesen Who-Am-I-Container starten.
Ja.
Einen Traffic starten wir nicht.
Ja, weil einfach...
Einfach nur 10er starten.
Der Compose.
Oh!
Das ist illegal, Leute.
Kein Wim dabei.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Anzeige, Abmahnung, äh, SWAT ist raus.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Das sollte echt verboten sein.
Guck mal, wir haben sogar Neo-Wim zu bieten.
Wir haben sogar Neo-Wim zu bieten, okay.
Da ist die Entwicklung auch ein bisschen eingeschlafen, ne, bei Neo-Wim.
Haben wir, haben wir denn auch nen grafischen, haben wir nen Wim, äh, Wim-GTK oder sowas?
Install, ähm, ja, sudo.
Übrigens, Leute, ich hab's euch schon 50.000 Mal diesen Trick gezeigt, ne, mit sudo, Ausrufezeichen, Aufrufezeichen.
Ähm, aber ich verwende ihn selbst kaum.
Das ist echt, kaum, kaum geht's um Texteditors, geht, geht, jetzt ist alle, alle wieder, ähm.
So, haben wir das, haben wir das kompiert, ja.
So.
Okay, halbwegs ordentliche Default-Settings.
Auch das Standard-Farbschema und so.
Passt, kann sich sehen lassen.
Der sollte jetzt in, äh, ab.
Der sollte jetzt in Kon...
Oh.
Docker ist nicht gestartet.
Warum nicht?
Weil, kein Bock.
Okay.
So.
Docker.
PS.
Ne, läuft nicht.
Okay.
Ähm.
Oh, fuck, was muss man da jetzt mittlerweile starten?
Äh, probieren wir mal aus Start.
Ist es Container-D, Docker?
Ne, einfach nur Docker.
Oder Container?
Ne, Docker.
Docker, was haben wir denn zur Auswahl?
Socket Service.
Start.
Okay, darf ich jetzt?
Get Permissions.
Haha.
Darf man als Root?
Als Root darf man.
Das ist eigentlich okay.
Ähm, dann machen wir das jetzt einfach mal als Root.
Äh, drumherum zu gucken.
Ob es funktioniert.
Äh, wo hab ich das denn jetzt angelegt?
Äh.
In welchem Verzeichnis hab ich das jetzt angelegt?
Hier, doch.
Home, ahjaja.
Sind wir doch, sind wir doch richtig.
Docker.
Docker compose ab.
Ähm.
Ja, funktioniert.
Es war also gut.
Es war so, wie man es machen sollte.
Du musst dein U...
Jaja, ich weiß, ich weiß, dass man das machen muss.
Aber ich will jetzt nicht.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Starting on port 80.
Local host 80.
Achso, geht ja nicht.
Ich hab ja keinen port-exposed.
Geht nicht.
Logisch.
Kann nicht funktionieren.
Ähm, dann.
Ähm, brauchen wir mal.
Haben wir einen TMAX zu bieten?
Welche Version haben wir davon?
Was haben wir da für eine Version?
Ah, Gott.
Warum, warum hat jedes Kommando eine andere Option, um rauszufinden?
Was man für eine Version hat.
TMAX Version, was haben wir da zu bieten?
Drei Punkt Dings Alpha.
Was ist die letzte TMAX Version?
Zwo, neun.
Okay, die ist schon ein bisschen älter, die dabei ist.
Die ist ein bisschen älter.
Aber kann man, kann man mit leben.
Vor allem der Q-Chat ist am Start.
Ja, das ist genau das gleiche.
Recursive, minus kleine R, minus große R. Ja, das ist genau das gleiche. Recursive, minus kleine R, minus große R.
Das können sich alle nicht entscheiden.
Bei SCP ist es minus klein R.
Bei Userberechtigung ist es groß R.
Bei CREP ist es glaube ich
auch groß R für Recursive.
Feind hat erst gar keine Option.
Das macht standardmäßig Recursive.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen
Wildwuchs, was Linux Kommando
Zeilentools angeht.
Es sind doch nur drei. Unix-like, BSD-like
oder GNU-like. Ja, dann sag mir mal,
was Java verwendet jetzt.
Ich glaube, ich habe schon so alle
Optionen, alle
Kombinationen gesehen, die es irgendwie gibt.
Ich kenne minus, minus
Version.
Minus V, minus Version.
Manche sind ganz abgedreht, die machen
nur Version.
Ähm.
Voll für den Arsch.
Java, ja. Wo ist eigentlich
mein Kaffee? Java, Pepe,
Kaffee. Hatten wir heute noch gar nicht.
Aber bis jetzt gefällt
mir das eigentlich ganz gut. Was hat man sonst noch hier?
Ja gut, brauchen wir nicht.
Welche Git-Version?
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Version.
Ich glaube, Git kann man auch
so machen, ne? Das ist nicht mein...
What the fuck? Warum?
Geht, geht...
Moment, geht minus V auch?
Nein. Minus Version?
Minus... Mal gucken, wir gucken jetzt
auf wie viele Varianten das funktioniert.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Anscheinend geht nur Version und Version.
Minus, minus Version, Version.
225. Ich hab aus dem Kopf
keine Ahnung, welche Git-Version aktuell ist.
Weil ich hab bei mir auf der
Arbeit einfach immer die aktuelle Git-Version drauf.
Ich guck da nie nach. Ich weiß,
es ist die aktuelle.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist die auch halbwegs aktuell.
Ja. 2.25
Sogar vor ein paar Tagen
erst released. Und da sind wir schon
am Start. Das mag ich. Das gefällt mir.
So, also da muss man sagen,
paketmäßig und so
echt alles in Ordnung.
So, npm und geschiss ist natürlich
auch drauf, weil
ähm
ist, ist Dings hier, hier
die, die, die npm Konkurrenz im
Paketmanager müssen wir mal schauen.
Ah, tatsächlich.
Guck mal. Warum, warum
kann mich das Ding eigentlich nicht nach
nach nem root Passwort fragen?
Und ich muss jedes Mal
ein sudo davor machen?
Das ist ein bisschen doof.
Fänd ich schöner, wenn mich das Ding einfach fragen könnte
nach dem Passwort. Ok.
Dann, äh, ja, install
ucli. Gucken wir mal, ob der
Kram alles problemlos funktioniert.
Weil ich geh einfach mal davon aus, dass viele Leute
den Kram eben halt als
Entwicklerrechner verwenden.
Global? Brauchen wir das wirklich?
Global?
Solang global im Heimatverzeichnis
bleibt, ist alles gut.
Das, es ist so geil, ne?
Du installierst JavaScript Dinger
und der lädt das halbe Internet runter.
Es, es, es gibt, man
kann in JavaScript nichts mehr installieren ohne
eine duplicated warning.
Guck dir das mal an.
Das ist auch out of date. Alles out of date.
Ja, das ist
lightweight.
Das ist, ja, es ist
es ist nur das halbe und wenn man, wenn man
die Java, JavaScript Microinstallation
dann ist es wahrscheinlich sogar nur das viertel Internet.
Aber was der hier alles, was der
hier alles runter lädt für, ist der Wahnsinn.
So, ähm,
view, oh wie ging
das jetzt nochmal? View new?
What?
Ah, ich hab's nicht im Path, kann das
sein?
Was, was muss man da in Path
packen? Ich mach das so
selten. Was muss man bei Jan in Path
packen? Oder muss man einfach sich mal einloggen und wieder einloggen,
ein- und ausloggen?
Ne, äh, oh Gott.
Was muss man da in Path
reinpacken, dass es funktioniert?
What?
Ne, es ist nicht view, es ist eigentlich nur noch
view mittlerweile. Es liegt hier irgendwo drin.
Guck da, oh ja.
Da liegt's.
Also das da muss ich in Path packen.
Aber,
das ist doof. Gibt's nicht noch Optionen,
dass er das für mich macht irgendwo?
Ach hier, guck mal.
Ah, das ist gut.
Sehr schön. Das machen wir.
Einloggen, ausloggen
und, und,
ah jetzt. Und jetzt geht's.
What?
Warum?
Hä? Wait.
Moment, warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Ich hab das in meine Bash-Ads
hier eingetragen. Das muss eigentlich funktionieren.
Ne, ich muss meine Bash-Ads
hier nicht sourcen. Ich hab mich ausgeloggt
und eingeloggt.
Wenn ich mich aus- und eingeloggt hab,
jetzt geht's, ähm, da muss, da macht
der Nächste die Bash-Ads hier automatisch mit ein.
Keine Ah...
Oder hab ich mich nicht aus- und eingeloggt? Doch, ich hab mich aus- und eingeloggt.
Aber jetzt funktioniert's.
Was geht das? View new und dann
hier irgendwie Client App oder sowas?
Ah Gott, die Option.
Add. Ne, Create. Create.
Es ist. Create.
Genau. Also,
Select Features. Wir wollen den ganzen Mist,
den wollen wir nicht haben. Vor allem kein Linter.
Wer braucht schon Linter?
Komplett overrated. Bash ist nicht
T-Max. Naja, aber T-Max
startet Bash. Das heißt, wenn ich T-Max zumache
und T-Max neu starte,
dann startet er auch ne Bash neu.
Brauchen wir alles nicht. Alles,
alles weg.
Oh. No.
Yes.
So, jetzt installieren wir nochmal das halbe Internet.
Mit. Einmal neues Projekt anlegen.
Dies.
Ich mein, wir installieren nur ungefähr 14.000
Pakete für ne einfache Webseite.
Nur. Also, das ist ganz.
Oh, guck mal Leute.
Emoji Support in der Shell.
Defaultmäßig schon drinne.
Also, ich muss
echt sagen, so für ne
out of the box Developer
Kiste, macht mir
macht mir
Solus keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Der eine, du weißt schon. Moin.
Interessant.
Find ich gut.
Warum Emojis?
Weil, weil nice. Ja.
POC Red Tiger.
Zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Das find ich gut.
So, also. Gehen wir mal rein.
Und gucken, ob unsere Webseite funktioniert.
Jawoll.
Da ist sie.
Klappt.
Alter, ich find Emoji Support
im Terminal standardmäßig schon nicht verkehrt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie kompliziert es
mittlerweile ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern. Vor
so ungefähr
zwei Jahre oder so.
Wo ich mich mal hingesetzt hab und mein
Manjaro komplett neu gemacht hab.
War es echt ne Wissenschaft
für sich.
Ähm.
Da die richtige Kombination
aus nem aktuellen
Terminal, nem aktuellen
ähm
Font-Config,
ne Emoji-Schriftart
mit dem, mit dem
mit dem richtigen Emoji-Format,
weil es gibt ja, Leute, das ist
absolutes Minenfeld, Schriftarten und
vor allem, vor allem
Unicode-Geschichten.
Es gibt, glaube ich, drei
oder vier verschiedene Standards
für Schriftarten, wie man
Color-Emojis speichern kann.
Es gibt die Adobe-Geschichte,
es gibt die Microsoft-Geschichte,
es gibt die
Apple-Geschichte und ich glaub,
die Android-Chrome-Geschichte.
Es gibt vier verschiedene Varianten,
wie man, wie man Color-Emojis
in der Schriftart encoden, speichern kann.
Und, ähm.
Es ist,
es ist so
unglaublich beknackt eigentlich,
wenn man sich das mal überlegt, ja.
Dass da jeder wieder sein eigenes Süppchen baut und
wenn man sich mal überlegt,
was eigentlich alles dahinter steckt,
dass so ein, dass so ein, dass hier
so ein,
dass hier so ein Emoji überhaupt funktioniert
oder generell, dass
Unicode-Zeichen
überhaupt ordentlich funktionieren.
Na, okay, die Fonts
sind zumindest die gleichen.
Sind die Fonts die gleichen?
Nein, guckt mal, Leute, seht ihr's?
Firefox benutzt
seine eigenen Emojis. Man sieht, hier
sieht man schon mal schön den Unterschied. Sogar auf der gleichen
Plattform sehen Emojis
unterschiedlich aus.
Und das liegt in dem Fall, weil, ähm,
Firefox einen eingebauten,
eine eingebaute
Emoji-Schriftart mit eingebautem Font-Renderer
für Emojis verwendet und
das Terminal eben eine andere Emoji-Schriftart
mit einem anderen Format
wie Emojis gespeichert werden
und, ähm, irgendeine Mischung aus
GTK, Font-Configs und Pango
für Fonts.
Das ist echt Big Brain.
Wer das verstanden hat, der kann
auch alles andere.
Der Hype-Train ist bei 94%, Leute.
Der Scam-Train läuft. Auf, auf,
Leute, go, go.
Ihr kriegt, ihr kriegt, was kriegt ihr denn da für?
Ihr kriegt von Twitch, glaube ich,
irgendwelche Emotes, wenn der Hype-Train traint.
Gehst du auf
die GPN? Nein.
Mach ich nicht.
Amazon Prime gekündigt und kostenfrei abonniert.
Ja, dankeschön für das Abo.
Aber, dann kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht
lange abonnieren, wenn du Amazon Prime
gekündigt hast.
Ich hab ein
9-11 oder doch lieber
911. Fünf Monate.
Dankeschön. Machen wir ein paar Smoke.
Nice.
Ja, ich könnte jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter
rumrenten über, äh, Font-Render-
Geschichten, aber diese
ganze, ähm,
diese ganze Mischmasch aus
Unicode, Standards,
verschiedene Encodings, ähm,
Font-Renderer, Schriftatmung,
und so, das ist wirklich eine Wissenschaft
für sich. Das ist echt kompliziert.
Für viele Leute ist ja
UTF-8 gleich Unicode. Das stimmt
ja gar nicht.
Unicode legt ja einfach nur fest, was es für,
ganz grob gesagt, was es für verschiedene Zeichen
gibt, mit welchen Codes.
Äh, UTF-8
ist das eigentliche Encoding.
Unicode, auch wenn es sich wie ein
Encoding anhört, ist kein
Encoding, so wirklich.
Es, es, komm,
Font-Geschichten lassen wir einfach mal weg.
Ja.
Und für Unicode verbreitet
sind ja schon mal
vorneweg drei Sachen.
Das UTF-8, das ist so das Neueste.
Das Schöne an UTF-8 ist,
ich rente jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen über
Font-Geschichten und Emojis,
dass das Gute an UTF-8 ist,
dass es abwärtskompatibel zu ASCII ist.
Für die ersten 256 Zeichen.
Danach
ist UTF-8 ein sehr merkwürdiges Encoding,
weil es
kann sein, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle.
Ich bin mir aus dem Kopf nicht mehr ganz sicher.
UTF-8 verwendet
über
256, also
über einen Byte, verwendet das
das letzte halbe
Byte, um zu signalisieren,
ob danach
noch ein weiteres
Byte kommt
für Multi-Byte-Zeichen.
Das ist
total wirf.
Das heißt, UTF-8 ist auch nicht
ein erheblicher Rechenaufwand dahinter,
um zu checken.
Und Emojis sind glaube ich fast alle 4 Bytes.
Voll für den Arsch.
Bei UTF-16
kannst du dir den Kram
auch nur zum Teil spannen.
Ich finde, UTF-16 ist
das Schlechte aus beiden Welten.
UTF-16 ist das Schlechte aus beiden Welten.
Es ist 2 Byte.
Es ist nicht kompatibel zu altem ASCII Zeug.
Und 4 Byte Zeichen
passen trotzdem nicht rein und du brauchst
den ganzen Kram wie bei UTF-8.
Also entweder
UTF-8 oder 32.
Java und
.NET haben glaube ich UTF-8 intern.
Einfach
keine Emojis, so sieht es aus.
So, was ich jetzt noch schnell ausprobieren
wollte, wie das mit Emojis aussieht, wenn ich
Chrome installiere.
Ja,
das Undead-Lead, das kommt
ja auch noch dabei. Das ist ja nochmal eine Emoji-Eigenart,
dass die Kombination
von zwei verschiedenen Sachen
was anderes
ergeben. Also, dass
man dann beispielsweise, ja wie du gesagt hast,
dunkelhäutige Daumen hoch oder so
machen kann.
Command Bra.
Chrome wollte ich
installieren.
Und dann mal gucken, wie da hier die Seite aussieht.
Und dann sehen wir schon,
es sieht halt überall anders aus.
Mal hier so zum Vergleich.
So sieht es im Terminal aus.
Was ist das? Emoji 1?
Was meint ihr, was ist das für ein Font?
Ist das Emoji?
Könnte sein, ich weiß nicht.
Könnte Emoji 1 sein.
Noto Sans.
DDF, okay.
Hast du eigentlich mal Angular
ausprobiert? Ja, vor Jahren.
Vor Jahren, als es noch
Angular 1 war oder fast
sogar noch Test-Version. Danach nie
wieder. Und die neuen Versionen
haben mich auch extrem abgeschreckt.
Weil ich das Gefühl habe, kleine
Projekte für kleine Projekte ist
irgendwie nix.
Zumindest das, was ich mir angeguckt habe,
kommt spoiler-play-technisch ja schon fast an
Java-Anwendungen ran.
Okay, also jetzt starten wir mal Chrome
und machen das da zum Vergleich nochmal auf.
Ja, nervt mich.
Äh.
Guckt.
Und Chrome ist schon mal
komplett kaputt und
verwendet als Fallback
die alten, auch noch die alten
Android-Emojis. Nicht mal die neuen
Android-Emojis. Also, man sieht
drei Anwendungen,
drei unterschiedliche Emojis
und
komplett kaputt eigentlich.
Das ist so lächerlich, dass das
so kompliziert ist.
Die hier gefallen mir
am besten.
Ich glaube, das sind auch die, die Twitter hat, ne?
Sind das nicht die Twitter, sind das nicht die
Twitter-Emojis, die
Firefox standardmäßig verwendet?
Wartet mal kurz.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz rüber, der Fernseher geht nicht.
So, Max-Technik-Support
hat das ganze fachmännisch gefixt. Fernseher
geht wieder. Das Problem war, dass
der Unity-Media-Router, diese komische
Unity-Media-Speed... Speed... Ne, nicht Speedport.
Speedport ist Telekom. Äh, wie heißt
das Ding? Connectbox?
Dass die der Meinung ist,
wenn
die Verbindung zu Unity-Media
abbricht, alle Requests
auf eine Fehlerseite umleiten
zu müssen, auf der steht,
Unity-Media geht nicht.
Und damit kommt das Shield-TV
nicht richtig klar,
weil das Shield-TV
dann eine Webseite aufmacht, weil
es denkt, ich bin hinter einem
Access-Point, der
eine Webseite mit Anmeldungen
verteilen möchte.
Und da geht beim Shield-TV immer der Browser
auf, wo dann die Unity-Media-Seite
angezeigt wird, Unity-Media hat keine
Verbindung. Was total Fail ist,
ja, und das verwirrt natürlich die Leute dann immer,
weil dann auf einmal eine große Fehlermeldung
draufsteht. Ich hab schon fünfmal gesagt, ich hab gesagt,
drück einfach weg, geh einfach ins Hauptmenü,
mach Kodi an und gut ist.
Aber das ist richtig Fail.
Ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob ich das nicht irgendwie
blocken kann. Aber
mir ist noch nichts, mir ist noch nichts
Gescheites eingefallen,
wie ich das blocken könnte. Weil das ist ja was,
das macht die
Unity-Media-Connectbox
quasi bei einem normalen Request, wenn der
ins Internet gehen sollte. Das kann ich nicht blocken, weil
das ist ja ein legitimer Request. Und ich weiß
ja auf dem Router davor nicht,
ob Unity-Media down ist.
Boomer macht das Angst,
ja, ohne Scheiß, ist echt so.
Was du für einen Fernseher hast du denn?
Boah, irgendein Sony, 5 Zoll.
Ich hab doch ein Video
darüber mal gemacht.
Ich sag mal, welchen Fernseher ich hab.
Wie ist das denn, wie ist das, naja, Max,
ruhig. Wie ist das denn, Wohnzimmer?
Irgendwas mit Wohnzimmer? Hier!
Den da, den hab ich hier.
Mit nem Shield-TV.
Hier das Teil.
Kosten die eigentlich mittlerweile?
Ah, ist deutlich künstlerisch.
Künstler geworden.
Ich hab da, ich hab da, ja, als er neu war, hab ich
um die 2.000 Euro noch für bezahlt.
Jetzt ist er natürlich billiger, ist jetzt auch nicht mehr das ganz,
das ganz neueste Modell.
Das ist ganz gut.
Kommt das Google-Chrome-Tipps-Video? Ja, kommt noch.
Guckst du dir eigentlich
die neue Overwatch-Season an? Nein!
Und wisst ihr, warum ich mir
die neue Overwatch-Season nicht anguck, Leute?
Leute, ich geh mal davon aus,
Leute, die es verfolgt haben, wissen warum.
Ratet mal, warum ich mir die neue
Overwatch-Season, Overwatch-League-Season
nicht angucken werde.
YouTube, genau, SaitoTV.
YouTube. OI!
OI!
YouTube, Alter.
Warum
macht man sowas auf YouTube Gaming?
Man hat es bei
Hearthstone gesehen.
Hearthstone-Viewerzahlen für die letzten
Turniere
im Boden versunken.
Handelt Unity-Media-Box
deine DNS-Anfragen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich bin mir grad nicht sicher, wie ich
meinen Router konfiguriert hab.
Nee, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie ich meinen Router
konfiguriert hab. Also, ähm,
äh,
mach mal hier NS-Lookup, mach mal irgendwie,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, also,
das hier ist mein Router.
Achso, es ist,
es ist natt,
sehe ich das hier gar nicht.
Also, ich verwende intern für DNS meinen Router,
allerdings der Router, was der als Uplink-DNS
verwendet. Ich glaube,
ich hab den Google-DNS oder Cloudflare-DNS
eingestellt, aber ich bin mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher. Es könnte sein,
dass der tatsächlich
die, äh, Connect-Box
verwendet.
Das kann
sein. Ah, echt? Läuft Overwatch League
auf YouTube?
Da muss ich mal gucken, was Chat und Zuschauer
sagen. Ja, live.
Naja, geht doch.
Die Zahlen sind gar nicht schlecht.
Die sind, die Zahlen sind ungefähr so
hoch wie auf, wie auf Twitch. Ein bisschen
niedriger wie auf Twitch.
89.000 ist doch okay.
Hätte schlimmer sein können.
Hätte, hätte schlimmer sein können.
Oh, Leute, ich muss mal,
ich muss mal kurz auf,
ich muss mal kurz auf, ich bin gleich wieder
da.
Und, ähm, für Windows-Umsteiger
Deepin und für Leute, die einfach nur ne
Programmierkiste haben wollen, schalten wir
die Solos. Echt nen guten Eindruck zu machen.
Meine Vorschau ist übrigens wieder abgekackt.
Geht bei euch das Stream noch?
Die Vorschau ist wieder
amonkasmoke.
Control-F, Alter, 5
hat's gefixt, okay?
Ja, also jetzt bei mir auch wieder in der Vorschau, aber
die Vorschau ist kaputt
gegangen. Cute-Stream. Aber
cute as fuck-Stream.
Cute AF.
Der Chat. Heute wieder.
Hehe.
So.
Ähm. Okay.
Sehr schön. Ähm.
Gibt's noch ne Sache, die wir sonst noch ausprobieren sollen?
H-Top, ZSH,
T-Marks, das haben wir alles mit. Community.
Achso, ja, genau. Wie sieht's so, wie
sieht's
bei Solos Linux aus? Ich mein,
die Chrome-Emojis nicht funktionieren.
Sieht man mal wieder, wie fail das ist.
Generell diese ganze Font-Render-Geschichte.
Aber gibt es
ne ordentliche Reddit-Community?
Weil man braucht ja vielleicht auch mal,
wenn man jetzt nicht so viel mit Linux macht,
vielleicht braucht man auch mal ein bisschen Hilfe.
Okay. Solos hat ne Reddit-Seite.
I try Solos me.
Support. Haben die ne
Forum?
Was ist deine Lieblingsdistribution?
Ich benutze sowohl privat
als auch auf der Arbeit
Manjaro mit i3WM.
Äh.
Es geht um die von den Distributionen,
die wir ausprobiert haben.
Dass ich
Manjaro verwende seit Jahren
und damit glücklich bin, ist ja bekannt.
Ja, wenn's darum geht, ist
Manjaro auf dem ersten Platz.
Aber ich würd Manjaro nicht unbedingt jetzt als Noob-Distribution
bezeichnen, die für Einsteiger gut ist.
Das ist aber ein hässliches
Forum.
Das ist ein mega unübersichtliches Forum.
Ach guck mal, anscheinend
gibt's in der nächsten,
anscheinend gibt's in der nächsten Version
ähm
GPU-Rendering
oder sowas in der Richtung, wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig
Ach nee! Das ist nur
für Leute, die diese
Geschichte haben mit Notebooks
mit Grafikkarten, dann bringt das ja nix.
Support us.
Stimmt. Support us.
Wie kann man euch supporten?
Erstmal gleich spenden.
Wie viele Sterne
hat das da? Oh, okay.
Ähm.
Na, sonderlich aktiv
ist das Subreddit nicht.
Oh, das ist natürlich
eine gute Frage. Wie man Browser
mit GPU-Decoding installiert?
Natürlich keiner darauf geantwortet.
Sehr schön.
Wobei, es geht gar nicht um Browser, es geht um
generell Videoplayer.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
KDE.
KDE. Ich finde,
dass Qt eindeutig
das angenehmere GUI-Toolkit
ist im Vergleich zu GTK, ja.
Aber mit KDE als Desktop kann ich
lustigerweise nichts anfangen.
Ich versteh, ich, das ist
eine Sache, die kann ich, kann ich
und die will ich unter Linux nicht verstehen, ja.
Wie kann es sein, dass
sowas essentielles
wie, ähm, Grafikkarten
Video-Decoding
nur mit übelsten Hacks
oder gar nicht funktioniert?
Wie kann, wie kann das sein?
Was ist mit denen los? Es muss sich doch
keiner wundern, wenn die Leute
reihenweise enttäuscht sind,
wenn sie das verwenden.
Das müsste, das müsste
höchste Priorität sein.
Ich, ich habe keine
Ahnung, ich, ehrlich gesagt,
und, und, ähm,
Easykiller, ich habe persönlich keine Ahnung
über die Geschichte bei der ganzen Geschichte,
ja. Also ich, ich weiß nicht,
wer da wie, wo, was supporten
muss und, und wer,
wer sich wo weigert
und sowas, keine Ahnung. Aber es
ist lächerlich unterm Strich,
unterm Strich für die User.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass sowas essentielles
wie, ähm, Video-Decoding
im Browser nicht funktioniert.
Also, Hardware.
Ähm, und ich glaube nicht,
dass es an Nvidia liegt, ehrlich gesagt,
weil die Nvidia-Treiber,
die sind ganz okay
unter Linux. Die haben zwar
ziemliche Probleme, dadurch, dass sie eben,
so, so, so ein, so ein,
ja, Nebenprodukt sind
und, und, was halt auch
keine richtigen Schnittstellen im Kernel hat
und da immer so ein bisschen hinterherhinkt, aber
die Nvidia-Kernel sind eigentlich ganz gut und funktionieren
eigentlich auch okay. Ähm,
ja, auf Wayland, auf Wayland,
bis Wayland mal wirklich irgendwann
ordentlich funktioniert,
da bin ich ja mal, bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Ähm,
letztes Mal, wo ich Wayland ausprobiert habe, hat's
sogar Probleme gehabt, Anwendungen
richtig zu resizen.
Da hab ich auch gedacht, was, was mit denen los?
Ähm,
Wayland ist auch, so, auch
so ein typisches Linux-Desktop-Projekt,
was, was von Anfang an so
ein bisschen die Totgeburt
war. Man hat was, was
ganz gut funktioniert mit X, mit
XOR oder X11,
was allerdings eine absolut
unwartbare
Kackkiste geworden
ist, ja. Einfach, weil's alt ist,
uralt letztes Mal Zeug drin ist. Da
kam man auf die nicht ganz so blöde Idee
und hat gesagt, wir bauen
was Neues, ordentliches.
Aber Wayland hat so
viele
Baustellen und unfertige
Geschichten drinne. Ich hab letztens
den schönen Post gesehen, wo sich
einer drüber ausgelassen hat, was halt mit
wo's bei Wayland krankt.
Und das war alles schön nachvollziehbar.
Zum Beispiel hab ich, glaub ich, immer noch
High-DPI-Support-Probleme, ähm,
grad ganz viel, ganz viel Zeug,
ja. Und denen ist dann nach und nach
aufgefallen, oh Scheiße,
wenn wir alles supporten
wollen, dann müssen wir Wayland fast genauso
komplex bauen, wie was das Alte jetzt ist
und vieles funktioniert noch nicht richtig. Es ist,
es ist ne Scheiß-Situation für
für Desktop-Linux aktuell.
So, und dazu kommt noch so nen Crap,
wie das in Firefox
gar nicht und in Chrome nur mit
Patches Video-Decoding
funktioniert. Das, das kann nicht sein.
Ähm, wisst ihr, wie das
ist mit Intel-Grafikkarten
und Video-Decoding?
Geht das wenigstens gescheit?
Weil die Intel-Treiber sind ja ganz gut.
Äh, ja, wir können
Why Wayland Sucks.
Mal gucken, ob ich diesen
ob ich diesen Post
finde.
Nein, das war er nicht.
Ein
State-Linux-Desktop
Wayland.
Huh. Das ist ein Teil
davon. Das, das war auch in dem
größeren Post drinne.
Die hatten ja V-Sync-Probleme sogar in, in
ähm, in Wayland
letztens noch. Ne, das hier war's nicht.
Ne, ne, das war...
Wo ist das denn? Sucks?
Huh. Hm.
Wo war denn der Post?
Das war, das war richtig, das war richtig gut gemacht mit
Problemen, die gelöst sind in grün
und dann mit vielen Sachen, die, äh,
nicht funktionieren, aber lösbar sind
in, in orange und Sachen, die
designmäßig crap sind in rot.
Wie?
Was da?
Hä?
Hm. Hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab ja auch meine, meine Bookmarks
hier nicht.
Hier. Ne.
Fuck.
Wir, wir probieren mal DuckDuckGo
aus, ob wir da mehr finden.
Ne, ich find, ich find das nicht mehr.
Aber generell auch,
ich mein, X ist für'n Arsch.
Wayland hat auch viele Probleme.
Sie sind, die Desktops wirken
auch teilweise ein bisschen wie aus
2005 oder so.
Ähm, es, es...
Ich finde, dass
die ganze Linux-Desktop-Geschichte
so als Ubuntu
geboomt hat,
auf nem ganz guten Weg gewesen ist.
So zu der Zeit,
wo es cool war, dass man nen
Compets-Desktop verwendet hat.
Ähm, nen Compets-Des...
Also da, wo, wo die, wo, wo, ähm...
Wo Ubuntu noch nicht mit Unity
und so nem Scheiß rumgebastelt hat, ja?
Ähm,
da, wo Ubuntu grad richtig geboomt hat
und, ähm,
die noch nen ordentlichen GNOME-Desktop hatten,
da, wo es cool war, dass man Compets benutzt hat
mit nem, mit nem Würfel und so Zeug,
da war so viel, da war so viel Zug dahinter,
äh, was Linux-Desktop-Entwicklung
angeht, aber das wurde
die letzten
fünf, sieben, fünf, sechs, sieben Jahre
nicht besser.
So, und durch die, durch
durch diese, die ganzen Baustellen
ist es halt für normale
User ne richtige
Zumutung, Linux auf dem Desktop zu benutzen.
Die halt normales Zeug machen wollen.
Für mich ist das als
Entwicklersystem jetzt weniger nen Problem.
Ja?
Ich guck halt bei Youtube auf
aufm Desktop, ja?
Ähm, also auf, auf meiner
Windows-Kiste hier nebenan, ja?
Und in der VM hab ich mein Entwicklersystem
mit i3, mit, ähm,
Browser und, und Editor
und IDE auf und gut ist,
aber für nen normalen User ist Linux
aufm Desktop halt nur
bedingt geeignet.
Durch die ganzen Sachen, die halt
nicht funktionieren.
Und ich kann, ich kann es halt einfach nicht verstehen,
dass sowas wie
GPU-Decoding, also
Video-Decoding im Browser
mit Grafikkarte, dass sowas
nicht die mit Abstand
höchste Priorität hat,
die es gibt. Weil es kann doch nicht sein,
dass ich unter Linux, wenn ich ne,
wenn ich ne Youtube, wenn ich Youtube angucke
unter Linux, dass ich
dann ne CPU-Auslastung hab von 150%.
Und wenn ich vielleicht
sogar Videos angucken möchte,
die 4K, 8K sind, dann geht's
schlicht und ergreifend durch das ganze Geruckel nicht.
Ah, also,
leider
werden wir das so Linux-technisch aufm Desktop
nicht sehen. Tja.
Leider, ne?
Ich hätt's auch gerne, dass es ein bisschen erfolgreicher ist.
Aber da krankt's halt einfach an vielen
Stellen. Ih, die haben auch so ne
komische
Sidebar wie Windows.
Äh, noch zwei Fragen,
bevor ich weg muss. Spielst du eigentlich noch
Final Fantasy?
War's das 14 war das, ne? Online?
Ne, schon lange nicht mehr, schon lange nicht mehr.
Wenn ja,
warum nicht? Ähm, weil
das Spiel damals nahezu kein Endgame hatte.
Ja, ich hab das ja mit dem Fabian zusammen
gespielt, als das, ähm,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das erste Addon rausgekommen
ist. Was war das? Heaven, war das
Heavensward? Kann das sein?
Genau. Ähm,
gerade als Heavensward rausgekommen ist.
Und wir haben danach auch noch
ein bisschen weiter gespielt. Und das war sehr
schleppend. Und es gab im Endeffekt
so gut wie kein Endgame in dem Spiel.
Der Fabian hat halb nackt
in der Stadt rumgestanden, drei Wochen lang,
bevor er das Abo gekündigt hat.
Ist jetzt kein Witz.
Der stand, der stand
mit seinem Charakter immer halb nackig,
mitten auf so nem Podest in der Stadt.
Drei Wochen lang!
Und irgendwann hat er das Abo gekündigt.
Und da haben wir gesagt, okay, das gibt halt
wenig zu spielen in Final Fantasy
14 zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, wie's
jetzt ist, vielleicht spielt das ja noch jemand von euch.
Dass wir keinen Bock mehr hatten.
Clear Linux? Ne, haben wir
noch nicht ausprobiert, aber könnte man vielleicht mal ausprobieren.
Ähm, so.
Nächste Frage war, was hältst du
von Fedora? Ich muss dir
ehrlich sagen, ich hab noch nie lang Fedora verwendet.
Wir verwenden auf der Arbeit Red Hat,
weil halt Enterprise, Business
und Keduns, um genau zu sein, verwenden wir nicht.
Nur auf wenigen Systemen
richtiges Red Hat, auf den meisten ist es
CentOS. Ähm, dementsprechend
bin ich mit dem Handling, was
Red Hat basierte Sachen anbelangt,
vertraut, aber
Fedora auf dem Desktop hat mich nie großartig
angesprochen. Ich, ich
also, privat mach ich's halt
so, also, was heißt privat?
Äh, auf dem Desktop Manjaro
mit i3 WM, auf der Arbeit auf
dem Desktop auch Manjaro mit i3 WM,
auf der Arbeit auf den Servern halt Red Hat
und bei mir privat
auf allen Systemen, auf allen Servern
Ubuntu Server. Hey, wie würdest
du Python für den Raspberry entwickeln?
Was, was
meinst du genau? Also, was ganz gut
ist für Einsteiger,
die keinen Bock haben auf WIM und Text Editor,
die Insta-Linie PyCharm und
probier mal die Demo aus.
Die Jetbrains Dinger kann man
eigentlich immer wunderbar verwenden.
Die Sache ist halt die, du musst, also das darfst
du nicht auf dem Raspberry
ausführen, weil das braucht RAM ohne Ende.
Aber du kannst ja Python auch ohne Probleme
auf dem Desktop entwickeln.
Äh, oder du schiebst es rüber
auf den Raspberry und führst dann da aus, oder
machst einen SFHFS oder irgendwas.
Also du musst die IDE nicht zwangsläufig
auf dem Raspberry laufen
lassen, wenn du für ein Raspberry entwickelst.
So, ich schreib mir das mal auf, dass
wir Clear Linux ausprobieren.
Clear
Linux
Mal gucken, wie das aussieht.
Why Clear Linux?
Ist das ein
Origami Pinguin?
Wie kreativ
sind sie ja schon mal.
Möchte eine Kameraüberwachung vom 3D-Trader
mittels OpenCV machen.
Wow, jetzt wird's aber
advanced.
Warum OpenSV?
Warum nicht einfach
willst du da irgendwelche Image
willst du da irgendwelche Live-Auswertungen
von dem Kamerabild machen?
Das hat auch
Pac-Man, ja.
Das ist die heiße Art zu sagen, okay
Boomer.
Ja, es gibt tatsächlich welche,
die es übertreiben. Ich hab persönlich überhaupt
nichts gegen SystemD.
Ich hab überhaupt nichts gegen SystemD.
Wenigstens mal eine Sache, die halbwegs
Standard ist.
Und überall, fast überall gleich.
Ja, Moment, er schreibt
hier auch über Server-Software zum
größten Teil. Dafür sind, genau dafür sind
Container gut. Aber nicht, dass man
seinen Text-Editor im Container laufen
lassen muss.
Oh, der Sbarro ist da.
Cute Mod am Start.
Genau, ich brauch
keinen Wim im Container.
Man kann es übertreiben. Es ist
mit der ganzen Container-Geschichte
und der ganzen Cloud-Sache und was
aktuell, egal welches Passwort
man nimmt.
Man muss immer gucken, für was die Technik
angemessen ist und für was die Technik sich eignet
und für was es halt andere Varianten gibt. Ganz einfach.
Es hat überhaupt keinen
überhaupt keinen Sinn, sich auf irgendwas
zu versteifen.
Zum Beispiel
mein ganzes
Zertifikat-Zeug. Früher
hatte ich auch, weil ich es hier gerade sehe,
früher hatte ich den Nginx laufen
als Reverse-Proxy
und hatte Certbot am Start
und Certbot ein bisschen gescriptet,
was über den Cronjob aufgerufen
wurde und das hat sich dann über Cloudflare
ein neues Zertifikat generiert und bla
und sonst was. Mittlerweile habe ich auch
so, ich habe einen Docker-Container
laufen mit einem
Loadbalancer drinne oder einem Reverse-Proxy
je nachdem, wie man das jetzt nennen will an der Stelle.
Der für
mich über die Cloudflare-API
ein Zertifikat abruft, das automatisch
alles checkt und gut ist.
Also für manche Sachen sind Container
schon echt nicht übel, aber nicht
automatisch für alles. Nicht weil
das für eine Sache gut funktioniert, muss es
für alle Sachen gut funktionieren
und gerade für Tools, die man lokal
braucht, ist so ein Docker-Container
kacke. Warum sollte ich meine IDE
in einem Docker-Container laufen lassen?
Mit Snap
oder Flatpak sieht das schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Vor allem mit Snap sieht das schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus.
Das ist auch ein Container,
aber das ist kein Container in Form
von Docker, der halt sehr minimalistisch
ist und der
nicht sichtbar ist in dem
Sinn vom Hausbetriebssystem, sondern
es ist quasi ein Container, der mehr oder weniger
ins Haus-Filesystem eingehängt wird.
Das ist okay, da ist überhaupt nichts dagegen zu
sagen. Ja, Homeworld
ist jetzt bei
Init vielleicht, wobei es gibt noch mehr.
Es gibt
OpenRC gibt es noch und Gedulds, es gibt
schon alternative Init-Systeme,
aber ich glaube bei SystemD kann man es auch
so sehen. Das hat sich
tatsächlich durchgesetzt
in dem Sinn, weil es
einfach das macht, was es macht
und das auch ganz gut.
Bekommt man Solos eigentlich auch die aktuellsten
Nvidia-Treiber wie bei Manjaro?
Gute Frage, probieren wir mal aus.
Machen wir mal Manjaro wieder aus.
Machen wir mal Solos wieder an. Gut, dass ich es noch
nicht gelöscht habe. Gucken wir mal, was für
Nvidia-Treiber dabei sind.
SystemD funktioniert auch ganz gut.
Es kann
halt alles irgendwie.
Ich bin auch jetzt kein großer Fan davon,
dass man
unbedingt alles zwingend mit SystemD
machen muss. Ja, also
ich fand es unter Debian nicht schlecht,
als sie die Netzwerk-Config
noch mit ganz normalem
Interface-Config-Skript gemacht haben.
Das fand ich simpel
und zweckmäßig. Unter Ubuntu
haben sie mittlerweile ihre komische
if, nee,
Netplan
ihr Netplan-Zeug am Start,
was ich total wirf finde. Warum?
Brauche ich eine YAML-Config für Netzwerk-Zeug?
Ja, man könnte
es auch über NetworkD
von SystemD machen.
Das ist halt wieder das, was ich gesagt habe. Man muss halt gucken,
was in dem
jeweiligen Fall am besten passt. Und ich finde,
für Netzwerk-Config haben so
popelige Interface-Skripts
am besten gepasst. Da geht es ja auch
nicht irgendwie darum, dass es
langsamer wäre oder so. Ein Interface
ist mit einem Interface-Skript genauso schnell hoch
gefallen, wie wenn NetworkD mein Interface
startet. Vielleicht nicht,
Benchmark-mäßig genauso schnell.
Aber ich glaube, es hat noch keiner
einen Benchmark gemacht mit 50.000 Mal
Interface up und down. Und was ist schneller?
Das ist vollkommen unerheblich.
Das Ding wird einmal gestartet beim Start, ob gut ist.
Oh, wir haben Warcraft,
wir haben Reforged-Werbung.
Huge.
Achso, wir müssen erstmal U-Block installieren.
Warum hat U-Block so eine schlechte,
schlechte...
Ach, Moment, das sind die Falschen.
Hoch lebe ETC-Interfaces.
Ich fand, ETC-Interfaces für das, was sie machen,
sollte bis jetzt, was die an
Netzwerk-Config hat, noch am besten.
Ich mein,
NetworkD hat schon ein paar coole Sachen,
wie dass du beispielsweise Interfaces direkt
beim Booten umbenennen kannst.
Das ist ganz cool. Dann heißen die Interfaces,
früher hießen die Interfaces ja sowas wie
ETH0, ETH1. Mittlerweile
heißen die Interfaces unter Linux ja
keine Ahnung, ENS
01P
S0, S5 oder so.
Dann ist es ganz cool, dass man
sagen kann, okay, mit
NetworkD kann ich
die Dinger umbenennen, so in
das, was es wirklich ist.
Zum Beispiel hatte ich so auf meiner alten
Firewall-Linux-Kiste, die ich mal vor
einer ganzen Weile hier im
Einsatz hatte, da hießen
die Interfaces halt so, wie das, wo sie
dran angeschlossen waren, ja. Da hieß das
10-Gigabit-Interface 10G
unterstrich
internal. Oder das andere hieß
1G
Unity Media und sowas.
Das war ganz cool.
Aber trotzdem ist mir
das, äh,
ETC Network Interfaces
Dings da von, äh,
ne, einfach nur ETC Interfaces,
ETC Network Interfaces, von Debian fand ich immer
noch am schönsten. Das war einfach simpel und
zweckmäßig.
So, wir wollten einen NVIDIA-Treiber ausprobieren.
Wobei, wir machen das mal mit dem
GUI-Ding hier. Ey, NVIDIA.
Was haben wir...
NVIDIA Docker?
Ey, was ist das?
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, was das ist?
Was ist NVIDIA Docker?
Ist das...
Ah, das ist für CUDA
Gedöns. Aha.
Okay. Ja, Premium sind
da vor allem nix.
Ähm...
Ja gut, also.
Dabei gibt es...
Es gibt...
NVIDIA GLX
44044329
Was, was ist aktuell?
Was ist aktuell?
Wo sehe ich überhaupt was aktuelles?
Äh...
Letzte kurzlebige Branch.
Was?
Letzte Preis.
Letzte langlebige Branch.
Version.
Warum ist die letzte
kurzlebige Branch
Versionsnummer kleiner als die letzte
langlebige Branch?
Scheint aktuell zu sein.
Mein
aktuell ist 44059
Haben die, haben die eine...
Haben die eine
Versionshistory oder so?
History?
Archive. Wow.
Boah, das wird zu
wie bei Nvidia.
Da blick ich nicht durch.
Ähm...
Scheint mir halbwegs aktuell zu sein.
Je nachdem, von wann halt
44044 ist.
Das war auch ein geiler Satz, ne?
Scheint mir relativ aktuell zu sein.
Je nachdem, von wann es ist.
Huge Big Brain Satz.
Eigentlich ist das komplett
komplett umsonst, der Satz.
Komplett bescheuert.
So, also von Ende 2012
ist das
der Treiber, der dabei ist.
Das ist also halbwegs aktuell.
Vorletzte Update.
Beta-Treiber, die gleiche Version wie der normale Treiber.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Also, die Old Legacy Treiber.
Scheint doch halbwegs aktuell zu sein.
Das finde ich doch.
Okay, es gibt mehrere Versionen.
Es gibt auch noch
44048.
Moment, warum gibt es da wieder so viel Zeug?
Ganz ehrlich Leute, wenn ich
was installieren würde,
dann würde ich den hier installieren.
Das ist Developer, das habe ich gesehen, aber
was ist der Unterschied?
Irgendwelche Debug-Symbols noch
drin, oder?
Naja, es ist halbwegs aktuell.
Was den Eindruck...
Ich hatte eh schon einen guten Eindruck davon.
Das hat sich jetzt nochmal bestärkt,
nochmal bekräftigt,
dass das ganz gut ist.
Anfänger installieren bestimmt erstmal Docker.
Das kann cool sein.
Dass die erstmal Docker
Nvidia Docker installieren.
So, bei der Gelegenheit, ich mache mal kurz ein Update.
Keinerlei Schaden.
Erstmal eine Runde updaten hier.
Lassen wir das nicht wieder
im nächsten Stream. Erstmal eine halbe
Stunde updaten müssen.
Das ist jetzt übrigens kein Solos.
Das ist jetzt mein normales
i3 WM Manjaro.
Man merkt auch, es funktioniert einfach viel schneller.
So.
Habt ihr noch Fragen?
Wollt ihr noch irgendwas wissen?
Irgendwelche Sachen, die wir ansprechen müssen in dem Stream?
Morgen früh bin ich ja auch gleich wieder da.
Dauert ja nicht mehr lang.
Dann gibt es wieder
Sonntag-Aufwachens-Stream.
Was benutzt du als dein normales Linux?
Das ist ja, wie gesagt, mein normales.
Das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM.
Wofür benutzt du alles Docker-Container?
Also, auf der Arbeit benutze ich
das oft, um irgendwelches Zeug auszuprobieren.
Einfach, weil es danach wieder weg ist.
Also im Prinzip genau, wofür das Zeug da ist.
Ähm, privat
benutze ich, was läuft denn aktuell in
Docker privat? Ähm,
Nextcloud?
Ich muss mal überlegen.
Ich sag's dir gleich.
Ich guck einfach mal nach.
Weil ich glaub, es kann sein, dass ich das...
Ich glaub, ich hab mein
Compose-File gelöscht
hier.
Äh, also ich hab Nextcloud laufen.
Lass mich mal in mich gehen.
Ich hab Traffic als Reverse-Proxy drauf.
Der macht dann auch, ähm,
Zertifikatsgedöns
und sowas.
Ähm,
so ein automatisches Container-
Update-Ding.
Nen Doku-Wiki
Unify-Gedöns.
Was ist das für die Access-...
Ne, stimmt nicht. Das läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi unten.
Ähm,
ein
Fileserver?
Oh, ich weiß aus dem Kopf gar nicht.
Aber eigentlich, es ist bei mir
immer ein gutes Zeichen, wenn ich den Kram nicht aus dem Kopf weiß.
Das heißt nämlich, der Kram
läuft einfach.
Neuer Kernel
Reboot, ja.
Mal gucken.
Was haben wir für einen Kernel drauf?
LTS, gut. So, haben wir hier nochmal ein Update?
Erstmal hier nochmal ein Update.
Wohohohohoho.
Was ist denn da
alles am Start?
Was will der alles updaten?
Monka.
Okay. Chrome können wir erstmal
wegmachen.
Was ist in Insomnia?
Hab ich da installiert?
Was ist das?
Ah, das ist sowas wie Postman.
Das ist so das Ding, wo man
HTTP-Requests
testen kann.
Und damit, Kodi brauch ich hier
definitiv nicht drauf.
Kodi brauch ich hier definitiv nicht drauf.
Was ich da für
alles zu euch drauf hab?
Ich brauch mal alles weg.
Alles weg.
Bam.
Oh.
Oje, oje.
Weg, weg.
Yes.
Hehehe.
Postwoman, Postman, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, dass es tatsächlich ein Programm gibt, was
Postwoman heißt.
So, kann ich jetzt updaten?
Ah, jetzt kann ich updaten.
Moment, wir machen
jetzt den YOLO-Mode an.
Bam.
So, jetzt updatet er einfach, ohne dass
ich was machen muss.
Ähm, Etcher drauf.
Weil Elektronen
für USB,
Micro-USB-Karten flashen.
Ich
möchte gerne ein Programm verwenden,
zum Micro-SD-Karten flashen,
was 400 MB RAM verbraucht.
Aber nächste Woche C
und Python-Klausur. Kannst du mir Mut
zureden?
Der ganze Pointer-Kram ist so ungewohnt.
Na ja, gut, Python, also
mit Pointer gibt's ja da nicht viel.
Und bei C kommt's drauf an, ob du den
Kram verstanden hast.
Ich mach dir nen Vorschlag. Der eine, du weißt schon.
Adresse und Typinformation,
die nen Pointer ausmacht.
Weil, wie gesagt,
ohne das eine kannst du mit dem anderen nix anfangen.
Und an sich ist es
kein
Hexenwerk. Und ich glaube, es hilft
tatsächlich,
wenn man
sich das Ganze mal anguckt,
wie das extrem low-level
aussieht.
Das kann entweder ein Hallo-World-Programm
sein, was man sich einfach mal in Assembler anguckt.
Oder man macht mal irgendwie
zwei, drei kleine Sachen in Assembler.
Nicht viel. Aber da wird man
sehen, das besteht
zum größten Teil
aus...
nennen wir's mal
Ifs.
Aus Sprüngen und Bedingungen und
Speicheradressen. Das ist fast alles.
Fast. Ja, ich weiß, das ist
bei weitem nicht alles. Aber...
Im Prinzip
besteht das zu einem riesengroßen
Teil aus, wir springen
an irgendeine Speicheradresse
und
wir entscheiden uns, ob wir jetzt an eine
Speicheradresse springen oder nicht.
Und unter der Haube ist halt alles, was nicht
in deine CPU reinpasst,
irgendwo, an irgendeiner Stelle, in irgendeinem
Speicher, weil wo soll das sonst sein?
Und selbst wenn du Sachen in der CPU speichern
willst, musst du trotzdem sagen, wo.
Eine Variable
ist im Prinzip... Jede Variable
ist,
wenn man so will, eine Zeige auf irgendeinem Speicher,
weil irgendwo muss der Kram stehen.
Entweder steht er in der CPU in irgendeinem
Register, er steht auf der Festplatte
irgendwo, er steht
im Arbeitsspeicher irgendwo, auf
irgendeinem Speicher muss der Kram stehen.
Und je nachdem, wie der Speicher gemappt ist,
hat das Ding halt nun mal eine Adresse, die man
braucht, plus die Typinformation,
was an dieser Speicheradresse steht
und dann kann man damit was machen.
Ohne geht's nicht.
So.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alle Updates installiert?
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht zugeguckt. Habe ich jetzt alles
gemacht?
Ich habe jetzt gelabert und dabei
irgendwas laufen lassen. Ich glaube, ich habe alles
installiert, oder?
Ich mache es gerade doppelt.
Ja gut, das ist dann schon
der eine, du weißt schon, das ist dann schon
die etwas
advancedere Geschichte.
Deswegen bin ich auch der Meinung, dass C und C++
und vor allem C++
Wir streichen mal einfach
C++, weil C++ ist eine Sprache, die
würde ich nie freiwillig lernen oder halte ich für immer
ziemlich bescheuert
zu lernen, außer man ist halt in irgendeinem
Bereich,
wo das gerne verwendet wird.
Aber C++ ist halt einfach die
Wut der Hölle, was Programmiersprachen angeht.
So, eine Runde Reboot.
Deswegen
halte ich C generell für den Einstieg auch nicht so gut.
Und C++
halte ich nie für gut.
Echt, macht man in der Berufsschule C++?
Das ist der Witz. C++ ist einfach
der größte Scheiß aller Zeiten.
Oh!
Leute!
Oh je!
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht!
Ich habe zu viel Zeug deinstalliert!
Ich habe mein Terminal
kaputt gemacht!
Warum?
Oh, weil ich kein Font installiert habe!
Ich habe mein Fonte installiert!
Ähm...
Ups!
Warum habe ich mein Fonte installiert?
Ja.
Hack!
Yes!
Was? Wo ist mein Font?
Ich habe es doch gerade installiert!
Wisst ihr was? Reboot hilft. Reboot.
Wo ist mein Font denn?
Lol!
Lol weh!
Ah!
Leute, mein Font ist wieder... ist back!
Mein Font ist back!
Ah, yes, Font!
So, was hat der jetzt hier für Schmerzen?
Ich glaube, ich habe doch ein bisschen viel deinstalliert.
Error!
Okay.
I3 Status Rust. Was mache ich denn hier?
Error!
Äh...
Warum? Wow!
Threat panicked!
Oh je!
Was hat er...
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Vielleicht muss ich Rust updaten.
Ich update Rust mal.
Was hat er für Schmerzen?
Meine Leiste ist kaputt.
Ich hätte den Snapshot machen sollen
vor dem Update, ne?
Ich hatte in der Berufsschule zum Glück
kein C++ dafür, aber ja, war...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich schlimmer finde.
Doch, ich weiß, was ich schlimmer finde. C++.
Java ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Java ist halt...
überladen und unnötig...
unnötig viel...
viel Zeremonie drumherum.
Aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte
zwischen Java und C++, würde ich immer
Java nehmen. Wie gesagt, C++
ist die schlimmste Sprache überhaupt.
Hat er doch gesagt!
Ja, also, findest du die Fehlermeldung jetzt
super aussagekräftig?
Also, ich nicht.
Äh, das ist Manjaro Linux
in der VM.
In der Berufsschule hattest du C-Sharp.
Ja, wenigstens was Gescheites.
Ähm...
Ich lasse ihn jetzt nochmal den Kram neu kompilieren
und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert.
Dann gucken wir uns den Fehler mal genauer an.
Äh, sie sind sich nicht so einig.
Ich hab das jetzt auch schon gehört.
Bei uns an der Berufsschule, also da, wo ich früher war,
an der... an der hier,
an der schlimmsten... also, naja...
Wahrscheinlich nicht schlimmsten. Kommt einem selbst immer so vor.
Hier, Frankfurt.
Frankfurt, Werner-von-Siemann-Schule.
Frankfurt.
Die da.
Die mit sagenhaften 2,1 Sternen.
Die Berufsschule.
In der ich früher war.
Die übrigens genauso hässlich aussieht.
Also, so sehr gefreut hat sich da noch nie jemand.
Ähm...
Diese Berufsschule, die sieht aus wie im Knast.
Hier.
So sieht's da drin aus.
Wie im Knast.
In der Berufsschule.
Deswegen gibt's da auch keine Fotos.
Oh, das ist die Turnhalle, genau.
Deswegen gibt's da auch keine Fotos von innen.
Weil das sieht aus wie im Knast.
Das Foto hier,
was der Typ hier fotografiert...
So sehen die Gänge da aus.
Es ist hässlich, das Ding.
Und die Berufsschule
suckt einfach nur.
Da macht uns zumindest
mittlerweile, hab ich gehört,
nicht mehr, sondern gleich C-Sharp
für Leute, die neu anfangen mit Programmieren.
Eine der wenigen sinnvollen Sachen, die die Schule hinkriegt.
Ist nicht jede Berufsschule hässlich.
Das Schlimme ist in Deutschland,
dass die meisten Schulen hässlich und kaputt sind.
Und scheiß Equipment haben.
Ist eigentlich so überhaupt nicht
würdig
vor einem Land, was so viel Kohle hat.
Und das in sinnvollere Dinger stecken könnte,
als in das, was wir gerade aktuell
alles finanzieren.
Zum Beispiel in unsere Schule könnte man das Geld reinstecken.
Oder manche sagen,
wir können die Sachen ökologisch nachhaltiger machen oder so.
Wir holen uns Berater
und Gedöns.
Dann schaut euch mal russische Schulen an.
Also nur,
weil es irgendwo schlechter ist,
macht es die andere Sache
nicht automatisch besser.
Wenn ihr mal was Gutes sehen wollt,
guckt euch mal eine Schule aus Südkorea an.
Oder aus Japan.
Das sieht im Vergleich zu so einer deutschen Schule aus
wie geleckt.
Äh, Rackfress.
Fünf Monate Twitch Prime. Dankeschön.
Das geht immer noch nicht.
Okay.
Was...
Was hat der für...
Alter, was willst du von mir?
No option profile defined.
Ich mag das nicht,
wenn sie Breaking Changes in ihrer
Config machen.
Dann haben wir mal ein Beispiel.
Example.
Config.
Pro...
Profile.
Ne, gibt es doch hier auch nicht.
Konfig ist vollkommen okay.
Ach hier, man muss das angeben.
Ach, leck mich.
Was ist denn das?
Ich werde das jetzt einfach
deinstallieren und die letzte
Stable Version verwenden.
Gut ist,
wir nehmen einfach die letzte Binary Stable
Version und freuen uns.
Okay, haben die
irgendwelche kaputt gemacht?
So, die Musik ist vorbei.
Ha!
Siehst du, schon funktioniert der Kram wieder.
Easy.
Einfach verbuggte Version gewesen.
Okay, jetzt nochmal Rebooten, gucken ob alles
funktioniert.
Ja, sehr gut, Pfunst.
Sehr schön.
Sicher, dass da keine Dependency fehlt.
Naja, mag sein, aber dann ist das
Build Script kacke.
Wenn es deswegen abkackt.
Danach.
Na gut, ne, bei Rust geht
das nicht. Wenn da Dependency fehlt, dann
kompiliert das Ding nicht.
Da ist gerade der Kopf geplatzt.
Kann sein.
Naja, ich habe einfach die letzte Version
genommen, in der Hoffnung, dass sie funktioniert.
Das war nicht mal Big Brain Play,
das war einfach gut Glück.
So, habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
VMware oder VirtualBox VMware?
VirtualBox kann man nehmen,
aber VMware finde ich
auf dem Desktop im Handling angenehmer.
Bei meiner Berufsschule war zwei
Jahre lang ein Fenster kaputt, nur Folie drüber geklebt.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Der Techniker ist informiert.
Die Schule ist schrecklich.
Sidelane warst du da auch?
VMware ist nicht kostenlos, ne.
VMware Player war mal
oder ist noch, wenn man es findet,
kostenlos.
Ähm.
An Weihnachten
haben die immer ganz gute Angebote.
Günstiger
das Ganze
zu bekommen.
Alternativ,
was ich dir natürlich ausdrücklich
nicht empfehle,
gibt es
mit Sicherheit Seiten, wo man
ne?
Was ich aber wie gesagt nicht
empfehle, weil man kann sich da Viren
und Geschiss einfangen.
Dann lieber VirtualBox verwenden.
Oder 70 Euro ausgeben.
Oder 6,90.
Äh, 6,90.
Für Windows 5 PC.
Ob das
geht?
Oder ob die auf irgendeiner Serial-Seite
waren und sich einfach Keys kopiert haben.
Und die jetzt
verkaufen.
Weil der Unterschied von 69 Euro zu
6,50 ist schon, ist schon...
Was ist das heute?
Laternenfest.
Oh, das sind die Dinger,
die den Zoo abgefackelt haben, oder?
Solche Dinger.
Das sind doch so Dinger,
die den Zoo abgefackelt haben.
Sollen sie hier mal nicht auf die Idee kommen.
Lizenz-Keys bei Edeka.
Ja.
Gut, die sind billig, das stimmt.
Aber so billig auch wieder nicht.
Bei JavaScript lernt man aber
kein Programmieren. Doch klar.
Klar lernt man mit JavaScript programmieren.
Du lernst zwar auch sehr viele
merkwürdige Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, dass Not a Number nicht gleich
Not a Number ist und solche Dinger.
Oder mein Lieblings-JavaScript-Witz.
Ähm.
Ah.
Wie ging da?
Ja.
Mein Lieblings-JavaScript-Witz.
Was kommt hier raus?
Aber ich habe ja die Antwort schon gegeben.
Aber es ist gar nicht so einfach,
dahinter zu kommen, warum
JavaScript das hier,
wenn man das ausführt,
warum das da rauskommt.
Ach ja, zu i3-WM.
Noch eine Frage.
Steht das in der xinitconf drin,
dass i3 nach dem Login startet?
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist auch geil.
Stimmt.
Ja.
2 plus 2 minus 2
ist in JavaScript 20.
Und ich versuche mir gerade zusammen
zu reimen.
Warum?
Das da ist ein Text.
Ah.
Das da plus das da
ergibt 22.
Also der nimmt den Text.
Der nimmt den Text.
Und plus ist
ist quasi
nicht addieren,
sondern
aneinanderhängen in dem Fall.
Also sprich, dann kommt
ein Text 22
plus 2 macht er den Text
22 draus.
So. Und minus
ist dann in dem Fall tatsächlich
subtrahieren, wo er hingegen
er 22 wieder umwandelt
zu 20 vorher
und minus 2 rechnet.
Ah. Yes.
JavaScript.
Exzellent Sprache.
Exquisite.
So muss das sein.
Also ich hab das bei mir hier drin stehen.
Oder nicht?
Achso, ich bin in JavaScript.
Hier hab ich mein StartX drin stehen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das zeigen kann
oder ob ich da nicht irgendwelches blödes
Zeug drin stehen hab, was ich nicht zeigen will.
Aber bei mir steht das hier drin.
Einfach als letztes dann i3.
Dann musst du StartX machen.
Ich hab in der, in meiner
Shell dann
noch drin stehen, dass der nach dem
Login, wenn es
dass der nach dem Login quasi
wenns glaub ich von
Terminal 1 ausgeführt wird oder so
dass der nach dem Login
direkt StartX
macht. Aber
ich bin da immer ein bisschen vorsichtig
weil man kann sich da auch ganz
wenn man da ein bisschen Scheiße baut relativ schnell
aussperren. Wenn man zum Beispiel
dann mal auf die Shell zurück wechseln
muss, auf die, auf die, hier
das Terminal
und man lockt sich ein
und man kommt dann nicht auf dem Terminal raus
sondern ist in der Endlosschleife gefangen
zwischen Desktop der nicht funktioniert
und Terminal ist doof.
Deswegen muss man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Just Marv
6 Monate, huge exquisite
sub.
Nein, gar
kein Prime, ein richtig echter.
Dich nervt der
Rand oft, du meinst das hier?
Äh, das ist Absicht.
Das ist Absicht.
Das kann man einstellen.
Das ist weil der zwischen, zwischen Anwendungen
immer Gaps hat.
Der Standard i3 hat keine Gaps.
Ich hab extra Gaps eingestellt
und man kann das, man kann das konfigurieren.
Man kann das hier
hier kannst das einstellen.
Ob er das macht oder nicht.
Aber eben mich stört's nicht, ich find's
eigentlich ganz angenehm so.
Ich bin im Moment noch an der Werner von Siemens Schule.
Oh Gott.
Dann mein Mitleid, Beileid
und Mitleid.
Beides.
Was hältst du eigentlich von PowerShell?
Scheiße oder gute Alternative zu Python
oder ähnlichem?
Interaktiv, also für
interaktive Shell find ich PowerShell
doof, aber
für Automatisierungszwecke
unter Windows find ich PowerShell
gut. Unter Linux
wüsste ich nicht warum man PowerShell verwenden sollte.
Dank .NET Core
läuft PowerShell zwar mittlerweile unter Linux
aber da seh ich den
Anwendungszweck nicht. Unter Linux
hab ich als interaktive Shell, Bash,
ZSH, was auch immer, Phish
meinetwegen.
Für kleine Skript-Sachen halt auch ganz normal
Shell und
für andere Sachen hab ich jede
x-beliebige Programmiersprache, die ich brauche
zur Verfügung. Von Python, Ruby
für bisschen Skriptgedöns angefangen
zu allem. Also
PowerShell unter Linux erschließt sich mir da sinnlich.
Programmerhumor, warum
war man da drauf?
Ja, jetzt
war es dran.
JustMarv hat dem Slaver
Saver ein Stufe 1 Abo geschenkt.
Dankeschön, huge sub.
Oder huge sub gift.
Das ist mir zu big brain, das kapier
ich nicht. Das kapier ich nicht.
Chat,
erklärt mir den Witz.
Ah!
C ist im Ami-Notensystem
schlechter als B.
Ah, da muss man Kokona-bewandt sein,
dass man das versteht.
Ah, verstehe.
Lull.
Ja, das hatten wir alle schon.
Unlustig.
Java, es ist Java, Leute.
Es ist Java, was sonst?
Oh, das ist ne gute Seite.
Das ist ne gute Seite hier.
Das muss ich unserem Azubi
schicken.
Es gibt keine if-Schleifen,
sondern nur if-Abfragen.
Ich sag ja gerne Bedingungen.
Abfragen.
Das erste, was der mir erzählt hat,
nachdem er mir sein Python-Zeug gezeigt hat,
was er gebastelt hat,
hat er gesagt, if-Schleife.
Das ist was, wenn ihr mich triggern wollt,
Leute, sagt ihr if-Schleife.
Der ist nicht schlecht.
Den find ich gut.
Das hat tatsächlich
gewissen Realitätsbezug.
Jetzt müssen natürlich
alle if-Schleife schreiben,
weil ich gesagt habe,
ich kann das nicht hören.
Chat muss mich gebaden.
Kannst du Seiten empfehlen,
auf welcher man...
Oh, jetzt ist der Chat weggesprungen.
Auf welcher man Informationen
zu Linux allgemein oder Archlinux...
Naja, also bei Archlinux,
das ist die beste Linux-Seite,
wenn es um How-To's
geht überhaupt.
Das Archlinux-Wiki.
Ich glaube, das dürfte die umfangreichste
Sammlung an Linux-Wissen sein,
die es auf diesem Planet gibt.
Das Archuser
Linux-Wiki.
Manches gibt es auch auf Deutsch,
aber ich würde mich an die internationale Seite halten.
Und ansonsten,
wenn du deinen Desktop hübsch machen willst,
das hier.
Das ist Linux-Porn.
Beste.
Reklusive if-Schleifen sind besonders cool.
Letzter Chat.
Der muss jetzt übertreiben mit if-Schleifen.
Die Seite ist doch für'n Arsch.
Haha.
Gibt es eine Free-Version
vom VMware Workstation?
Nee.
AskIquarium, okay, okay.
Da hat man wieder Zeit.
Jetzt können wir uns ausruhen, Leute.
AskIquarium läuft.
Excellent.
Das wird jetzt Einschlaf-Stream.
AskIfirepit.
Keine Ahnung, ob es das gibt.
Es gibt das hässlichste Fire unter Linux,
was, ähm...
Hahaha.
Das ist irgend so'n OpenGL-Test.
Haha.
Das ist halt mega eklig, ey.
Guckt euch das an.
Man kann sich sogar bewegen, ne?
Man kann sogar... huge.
Man kann sogar laufen hier irgendwie.
Äh.
Ja, Leute.
Massive.
Huge Graphics.
Also...
Besser geht's...
Also, grafisch ist es ja wirklich schon hier mal voll.
Ah.
Also, da kann man ja mal gar nichts sagen hier.
Die Bäume allein schon.
Guckt euch mal an.
Exquisite-Bäume.
Äh.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hingeflogen bin.
Ich bin rausgeflogen.
Aber immerhin 1400 FPS.
Battlefield-5-Bäume.
Gewisse Ähnlichkeit ist nicht abzustreiten.
Könnte eine
64K-Competition sein.
Die sehen, glaube ich,
sogar noch... Sogar die sehen besser aus.
Sogar...
Die Demos vom Amiga
sahen besser aus.
Nein, nee. Ja, doch, doch.
Die waren stylischer.
AA-Fire-Driver-Curses.
Habe ich, glaube ich, nicht installiert. Oh, doch.
Excellent-Fire.
Oh, der mag das nicht.
Bisschen schnell, hä?
Mach mal bitte den weg.
Okay.
Das Start eher nicht reinmachen.
Doch, doch. Du kannst das Start-X
schon reinmachen in deine Shell.
Du musst nur gucken,
dass du abfragst,
von welcher Konsole
du da startest.
Oder dass du dir irgendwas einfallen lässt.
Für den Fall der Fälle, wo du mal auf die Konsole musst,
dass der nicht immer versucht,
X zu starten.
So nach dem Motto, guck, dass du in der ersten Konsole bist,
dann kannst du X starten.
Wenn du in der zweiten Konsole bist,
dann startest du kein X. Weil sonst hast du im Zweifelsfall,
wenn du debuggen musst, weil dein X nicht funktioniert,
eine Endlosschleife.
Versuche Desktop zu starten, Desktop crasht.
Das will man nicht.
Was geht hier gerade ab?
Eigentlich gehe ich jetzt gleich off.
Wolltest du noch alles beantworten, was im Chat so drinnen steht?
Wieso machst du immer öfters mal die 1
in die URL vom Browser?
Ja, die Leute haben ja schon das Kommando geschickt.
Das ist so ein Tick von mir.
Das mache ich öfters mal.
Und wenn es keine 1
zu copy-pasten gibt,
copy-paste ich irgendwas anderes.
Das ist so eine Angewohnheit von mir,
die keinen tieferen
Zweck erfüllt.
Außer,
dass ich mich besser fühle, wenn ich es mache.
Gut Leute,
nachdem ich ja morgen schon wieder
am Start bin.
Ich mache mal eine Frage.
Spielt jemand von euch,
oder ist jemand von euch bei Path of Exile
richtig, richtig pro?
Kennt er sich richtig gut aus?
Weil ich habe heute Morgen,
ich spiele ja auch gerade relativ viel Path of Exile wieder.
Ich habe heute Morgen
ein paar Leuten zugeguckt,
die in irgendeiner League
gestartet sind,
mit einem ziemlich suboptimalen Build.
Und die haben es geschafft,
in diesem Game,
fünfeinhalb Stunden
weiter zu sein
in der Progression,
wie ich nach
30 Stunden.
Oder 25 Stunden.
Und da war ich jetzt erstmal
on KS.
Und da ist mir mal aufgefallen,
dass ich absoluter Noob bin in dem Game.
Ich meine Path of Exile hat mittlerweile
so viele Mechaniken
und unterschiedliche Sachen,
die man machen kann, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Die haben eigentlich gar nicht so viel benutzt.
Die haben einfach nur
sauschnell
die Kampagne durchgespielt.
Zu zweit.
Der eine hat
gelevelt, der andere hat
Kampagnenmissionen gemacht.
Und die waren nach
knapp
drei Stunden
waren die mit der
Kampagne durch.
Hast du schon mal versucht,
etwas mit dem Plutus-Modul zu programmieren?
So direkt nicht.
Ich habe schon Plutus mit einem ESP32 gemacht.
Wolltest du jetzt
Clean Linux vorstellen?
Ne, das machen wir in einem der nächsten Streams.
Weißt du, ob man eine Chromecast flashen kann?
Keine Ahnung.
So Leute, ich bin morgen früh wieder am Start.
Wir sehen uns dann wieder so
gegen, ich denke mal so
10 Uhr, halb 10.
Irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
Easy.